So, geht das Mikrofon? Ja, das weiß man bei Windows ja nicht immer so.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, mach mich was Entspannenderes an.
Ah, stimmt, ich wollte noch ein Video, das müssen wir gerade mal aufmachen.
Gesehen, der Auer hat wieder ein Video gemacht zum Thema Intel CPU.
Das wollte ich mir angucken, das können wir uns später zusammen angucken,
dass ich weiß, ob ich meine CPU jetzt wegschmeißen muss oder nicht.
Na gut, wegschmeißen muss, müssen tue ich die nicht.
Man weiß halt nicht so genau, wie sich das entwickelt, wenn die kaputt geht, ob die richtig betroffen ist.
Ich habe noch keine Liste von Intel gefunden, wo draufsteht, welch CPU es jetzt,
wie man irgendwie rausfinden kann, was genau betroffen ist.
Also ich weiß, dass theoretisch meine Serie betroffen ist,
aber man kann nichts irgendwie gescheit rausfinden.
Das ist alles sehr vage.
Mal davon abgesehen...
Ich muss jetzt eh warten, bis, zumindest habe ich das bei Heise oder so irgendwo gelesen,
dass die im August wollen die wohl breitflächig BIOS-Updates rausbringen.
Was das in irgendeiner Art und Weise fixt, aber auch nicht alles, keine Ahnung.
Also zumindest bis jetzt hat meine CPU keine Probleme, aber das heißt ja nichts.
Ich meine, das merkst du halt erst, wenn es zu spät ist.
Und dann wird das Ding immer instabiler.
Es wird kaputt und dann brauchst du einen neuen Rechner.
Na, alle, das kannst du so nicht sagen, dass alle betroffen sind.
Es sind potenziell die 13. und 14. Generation betroffen.
Es sind, genau, es sind prinzipiell nur eher die High-End-Diggeren-CPUs betroffen,
aber auch nicht jetzt irgendwie komplett über alles.
Die haben es ja seit einer Weile schon gemerkt.
Also es ist gar nicht so einfach, da gescheite Infos rauszukriegen, auch von Intel.
Archer, by the way.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Updates.
Und würde meine Tastatur rausziehen und wieder reinstecken, weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen
mein Logi...
Schon wieder.
Alter, was macht dieser Logitech-Treiber?
Lull.
Normalerweise...
Warte mal.
Ich zieh das nochmal raus, nochmal rein.
Ja.
Okay, jetzt geht's.
Aber auch nicht richtig.
Alter, was ist denn...
Was macht Logitech da für Dinger?
Normalerweise sollte meine Tastatur blau leuchten.
Das ist irgendwie ein Bug.
Wartet mal.
Logitech.
Mit.
Was ich für eine Maus habe.
Ich hab eine Pro Wireless.
Light Speed.
Ne.
Achso, ach, das ist die...
Die Kommunikationstechnik.
Problem.
Also ich hab...
Man sieht's ja hier im Endeffekt, wenn ich das aufmache.
Hier, Logitech.
Jaja.
Ich gotte es.
Ich hab diese Maus plus dieses Mauspad.
Dieses Mauspad lädt die Maus auf.
Also es ist...
Es ist superpraktisch.
Richtig nice.
Ich war am Anfang auch skeptisch, ja.
Ich hab mir am Anfang gedacht, oh.
Eine Wireless...
Ich bin ja überhaupt kein Wireless-Maus-Fan gewesen.
Obwohl das jahrelang eigentlich schon ganz brauchbar funktioniert, ja.
Ist eine Wireless-Maus und sonst wie.
Aber die Kombination aus dem Mauspad, was die Maus auflädt und die Maus selbst wireless, ist echt gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das noch gibt oder wahrscheinlich gibt es da mittlerweile schon irgendwie die fünfte Generation von.
Die Maus ist gut und das mit dem Aufladen ist nice.
Ich musste noch nicht einmal irgendwas an dieser Maus machen, das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert deutlich besser als die Tastaturen von Logitech.
Mit Tastaturen von Logitech...
Guck mal, die sollte eigentlich aktuell blau leuchten.
Die leuchtet aber nur zur Hälfte blau.
Das buggt.
Also einen Link schicken von einem Discord.
Wir haben noch einen Discord-Link, oder?
Das ist kaputt.
Wir müssen den Discord-Befehl ändern.
Heck weh.
Ähm...
Es müsste...
Wo bloß?
Ne, ich tue es mal.
Ja, anscheinend ist der Discord-Link kaputt.
Beziehungsweise, der Discord-Link ist nicht kaputt, das Weiterleiten ist kaputt.
Warte mal.
Da muss ich jetzt selbst mal kurz gucken.
Ja.
Okay, nice.
Da haben wir schon mal einen Discord-Link.
Ich passe das gerade mal an.
Was hatte ich?
Nightbot.
Bin ich überhaupt eingeloggt dafür, dass das funktioniert?
Login.
Login with Twitch.
Ja.
Oh, fuck.
Mein Twitch-Passwort.
Öp.
Muss ich mal nachgucken.
Twitch.
Okay.
SMS-Code.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, ey.
Remember this computer, ja.
Ich...
Ich passe mal...
Ich passe das mal an.
Ich passe mal den Discord-Link an.
Wusste gar nicht, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Nightbot.
Commands.
Discord.
Boah, wie viele Commands wir hier haben, ja.
Die meisten davon haben wir noch nicht verwendet.
Okay, ich passe das mal kurz an.
Submit.
So, jetzt probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Discord.
Okay.
Pons.
Oggo.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz checken, dass mein Linux-Clipboard nicht mein Twitch-Passwort
irgendwie ins Clip kommt.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob mein Twitch-Passwort mitgeklippt hat.
Nee, hat's nicht.
Hat's nicht.
Das muss nämlich nicht unbedingt sein.
Mein Twitch-Passwort irgendwie leaker.
Ja, wir brauchen auch zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung, aber...
DM, du kannst einfach hier fragen, wenn es irgendwas von allgemeiner Relevanz ist.
Der Link von mir ist aber nur sieben Tage gültig.
Ach ja.
Ja, das mache ich nachher.
Twitch...
Twitch-Link.
Nee, ich nehme keine Leute auf Discord an, wenn ich nicht weiß, um was es geht.
Ich hatte schon ganz, ganz viel Weird-Jump in diese Richtung.
Was du machen kannst ist, wenn es irgendwas ist, was du nicht public schreiben kannst,
du kannst an meine Business-E-Mail schreiben.
Die steht auf YouTube und die steht auf Twitch.
Und da gucke ich dann rein.
Das geht, aber auf Discord nicht.
Der Hoverlord ist am Start.
So, jetzt mache ich mal kurz...
Ähm...
Eine Runde Updates.
Boah, da hatten wir aber schon ganz schön lange nichts mehr.
Ja, Chatge, stellt euch vor, in ein paar Tagen...
Ah, nicht ganz, aber...
Na doch, ein paar Tage ist ja sehr dehnbar.
In ein paar Tagen bin ich 40.
Weird-Jump, oder?
Wir haben gar keinen Old...
Haben wir irgendwo einen Old-Emote?
Wupp-Old?
Wir hatten mal einen Wupp-Old.
Old?
Weißt du, was ich sage?
Wir hatten mal einen...
Ach doch, haben wir doch.
Was?
Den muss ich mal in die Emotes mit aufnehmen.
Geht man mit 40 schon als Old durch?
Oder ist das erst 60 plus, wo man Old ist?
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, mit 40 ist man da auf jeden Fall schon dabei.
Das ist man ja quasi ab 23 oder so schon.
Wenn ich mir angucke, was da unterwegs ist, zum größten Teil.
Ja.
Egeleis-Feed.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Ich habe bestimmt irgendwas übersehen bis jetzt.
Hoffentlich.
Nee, ich brauche keinen.
Ich brauche keinen Bot.
Also wenn...
Wüsste ich gar nicht, was ich dazu machen müsste, dass ich...
Was wäre da...
Advanced-Zeug...
Also...
Nee, nee, nee.
Brauche ich nicht.
Also dafür mache ich zu wenig...
War mir zu wenig über Discord.
Discord ist eigentlich nur entstanden damals.
Weil die Leute immer noch am Discord gefragt haben.
Und wenn man sich anguckt, was die Mod-Gesicht teilweise für...
Blödsinn durchlesen müssen im Discord.
Bin ich froh, dass wir nicht mehr über Discord machen.
Da ist ja teilweise echt ganz weird-champiges Zeugs dabei.
Ja, ja.
Nee, nee, brauche ich nicht.
Ich...
Ich bin ja gar nicht mehr im Surfer-Raum.
Das ist ja das Ding.
Ich würde ja eigentlich ganz gerne mal wieder.
Aber...
Da, wo ich jetzt arbeite, da haben wir nichts im Rechenzentrum zu tun.
Ich wüsste noch nicht mal genau, wo das ist.
Das ist echt...
Hat sich ganz schön gewandelt, ja.
Vor 15 Jahren.
War ich noch jeden Tag im Rechenzentrum.
Mehrfach.
Jo, alles klar.
Und mittlerweile seit Jahren gar nicht mehr.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, so ab und zu...
Ab und zu würde ich schon mal gerne wieder ins Rechenzentrum.
Und einfach sinnlos irgendwas einbauen und verkabeln.
Und dann...
Ich habe es ja letztens...
Ich habe es ja letztens geschrieben.
Und dann am besten noch...
Sinnlos Linux installieren von einer DVD oder so.
Mit so einem Rechenzentrum.
Monitorwagen.
XZQ not found.
Okay.
Wow.
Was mit meinem Terminal passiert?
Also die Jetbrains Toolbox ist irgendwie broken.
Die hat irgendwelche Probleme.
Ja, und falls ihr das jetzt gerade gelesen habt.
Nein.
Es geht hier um ein altes...
Es geht um ein altes Video von mir.
Weil manche beim Durchgucken der History...
Immer diesen Titel lesen.
Sagt's, Max, was hast du für komische Videos in der History?
Nein, das ist ein altes YouTube Video von mir.
Warum ist die Jetbrains Toolbox weg?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Warum ist die...
Hat die sich aninstallt jetzt oder was?
Sass, ja.
Die hat sich an...
Warum ist meine...
What the fuck?
Ist das meine Idee?
Die sind noch da.
Okay.
Whatever.
Leute.
Reboot.
Das wird alles fixen.
Ja.
Schon ein bisschen.
Habe ich noch Snapshots, die man wegschmeißen könnte?
Vom...
Sieben...
Den Snapshot brauche ich garantiert nicht mehr.
Ich kann euch auch nur empfehlen, Snapshots zu löschen,
weil die Dinger werden richtig groß mit der Zeit.
Weil da wird sich halt immer der Diff gespeichert.
Zwischen aktuell und dem Snapshot-Zeitpunkt.
Das wird richtig groß.
Also egal, was ihr auf der VR macht,
es wird alles als Diff gespeichert.
Und dementsprechend wächst das schnell.
Das Löschen der Snapshots ist teilweise richtig lahm.
Ach so, was ich eben noch sagen wollte.
Genau, wo ich angefangen habe.
Also, alles top.
Die Tastatur geht auch.
Auch klar.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich.
Mit Logitech-Tastaturen, generell mit Tastaturen,
habe ich die letzten Jahre über keine guten Erfahrungen gemacht.
Also, ich habe zwei Logitech-Tastaturen durch
und eine Corsair-Tastatur.
Und die hatten alle unterschiedliche Probleme.
Die jetzt, die ich hier habe,
die geht jetzt halbwegs,
aber auch nur, weil ich die wirklich sehr...
Ja, sehr weich immer nur, ja, sehr vorsichtig immer nur angreife.
Dieses, also, weißt du,
ich weiß nicht, was mit der Bildqualität von Tastaturen die letzten Jahre über so passiert ist.
Aber die sind sehr...
fragil geworden.
Für mich waren Tastaturen eigentlich immer so eines der stabilsten Dinger,
wo du im Zweifelsfall Einbrecher mit erschlagen konntest.
Oder vielleicht musst du ja die Einbrecher nicht gleich erschlagen.
Wo du Einbrecher mit abwehren konntest.
Mittlerweile...
Weiß ich das nicht so genau.
Also, eines meiner größten Probleme mit den...
mit dieser Tastatur, die ich hier gerade habe,
die macht im Großen und Ganzen das, was sie soll.
Ja, also, mit...
Also, insofern ist das schon ganz in Ordnung.
Größte Probleme, die ich aktuell habe mit dieser Tastatur.
Zum Beispiel, dass in...
Ah, jetzt hat's gecheckt, dass angeblich blau sein soll,
aber es ist nicht alles blau.
Also, ähm...
Manche...
Beschriftungen sind schon...
Wobei man ja eigentlich denken würde, es ist keine klassische Beschriftung.
Das ist eigentlich eher so ein Loch, wo das Licht durchscheinen kann.
Aber trotzdem...
Manche Beschriftungen scheinen schon nicht mal richtig das Licht durch.
Wie auch immer das funktioniert,
ja, wahrscheinlich die Dreck...
Der Dreckbelag zu groß, aber man kann's auch nicht abputzen aus irgendwas der...
Vielleicht...
Aber das ist überhaupt nicht das Schlimme.
Das stört mich eher nicht so großartig.
Was mich...
Was mich mehr stört an der Tastatur ist,
dass die Tasten so...
locker drauf sitzen.
Zum Beispiel, was man ja mal ganz gerne macht, ja,
wenn die Tastatur beispielsweise
ein bisschen zu weit links liegt,
dann greift man die Tastatur hier unten an,
ja, so hier so an diese Ecke,
und schiebt die ein bisschen weiter nach rechts.
Und man muss wirklich aufpassen,
wenn man zu viel Druck auf die
Control-Taste ausübt beim Schieben,
dann ploppt die runter.
Und wenn die ein paar mal richtig hart runtergeploppt ist,
dann wackelt die.
Das ist eins der Probleme.
Das sind alles so Dinge,
wo ich mir denke, das Zeug war früher
doch nicht so fragil, Mann.
Ja, das sollte nicht sein.
Und dazu kommt, dass du für dieses
Ding...
Du musst dir eigentlich eine Handballenauflage kaufen,
weil die so unergonomisch unten ist.
Ich mach mal kurz die Handballenauflage weg.
Ey, das kannst du komplett vergessen.
Das...
Der drückt sich die Kante,
der Tisch schon
unten in den Arm rein
beim ersten Versuch.
Also du musst dir eine zusätzliche...
Die ist natürlich da nicht dabei, das wäre ja auch zu einfach.
Du musst dir noch unbedingt eine zusätzliche
Handballenauflage kaufen, sonst kannst du es
komplett vergessen.
Microsoft redet sich raus, ja.
Die schwätzen alle.
Ich meine,
nachdem was passiert ist, das Billigste,
das kann man sich merken, das Billigste immer ist
Reden. Deswegen reden die immer
ganz viel die Sachen klein, nachdem
irgendwas verkackt wurde.
So, mal gucken, ob meine JetBrains Toolbox jetzt...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
hat sich meine...
What the fuck? Warum hat sich meine...
Warum hat sich das einfach
uninstalled? Muss ich das hier haben?
Habe ich das uninstalled mal irgendwann?
Hier gibt es die auch nochmal.
Hier gibt es die nochmal.
Ich bin hochgradig verwirrt.
Warum gibt es die mehrfach?
Moment, und wie ist das über mein Start-Ding?
Toolbox?
Moment, darüber lässt sie sich starten?
Okay, ich bin
übelst verwirrt.
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist alles gut und
ich habe noch meine JetBrains Toolbox,
aber...
Wir machen Updates. Ich wollte eigentlich Updates machen.
Updates. Excellent.
Hast du... Nee.
Ich wollte das Video vom Bauer angucken nachher,
weil ich da selbst nicht so richtig durchblicke.
Also was ich gecheckt habe,
ist, dass es anscheinend zwei verschiedene
Probleme gibt. Es gibt wohl
einmal dieses Problem,
dass Intel CPUs zu schnell
altern.
Irgendwie
fabrikmäßig bedingt.
Da kann man nicht wirklich
was dagegen machen.
Und dann gibt es das nächste Problem, das zweite Problem,
dass Intel CPUs zu schnell
altern, weil die irgendwie eine
falsche Firmware quasi haben.
Und...
Das in Kombination ist besonders kacke,
weil das eine das andere beschleunigt.
Ich habe das grob überflogen irgendwo bei Heise
oder so. Oder auf Reddit ein bisschen
geguckt. Ich habe wirklich großartig Ahnung, habe ich auch nicht
davon. Und das eine
beschleunigt irgendwie das andere. Deswegen gibt es ab
April... Nee, nicht April. Ab
August soll es dann grob...
Also so
grob im August soll es dann großflächig
Firmware-Updates geben, was
diesen Bug wohl angeblich behebt.
Ja...
Also ich muss sagen, ich finde da die
Kommunikation, beziehungsweise die
Veröffentlichung von Intel
sehr lacking, was das Ganze
angeht. Weil man hat gar keine Ahnung,
ob seine CPU jetzt wirklich davon
betroffen ist oder nicht.
Also man weiß, dass 13 und 14 eine
CPU-Generation betroffen ist. Vielleicht,
eventuell. Und was davon, weiß man auch nicht
so genau. Man weiß zumindest... Also eine Sache weiß man,
dass nur die
etwas teureren und schnelleren
CPUs davon betroffen sind. Also die ab 65
Watt...
Wie heißt das?
TPM oder so?
Thermal Power...
Ach, ihr wisst, was ich
meine.
Ah, nee, nee, nicht TPM. TPM war was anderes.
Thermal...
TDP.
Aber man weiß auch nicht, welche
CPU-Serien genau und man weiß
auch nicht, von wann bis wann denn jetzt
die fehlerhaften hergestellt wurden.
Das ist alles ein bisschen vage. Ich habe so den
schönen Eindruck, Intel weiß es selber
nicht so genau. Sonst hätten die sich ja
vielleicht ein bisschen
genauer geäußert. Oder es ist noch
viel umfangreicher,
als wir denken
und Intel sagt nichts,
damit man das nicht rausbekommt.
Das kann natürlich
alles sein. Man weiß es nicht.
Ja, es wird schon oft gesagt, dass Intel
am Arsch ist. Intel war nie am Arsch.
Auch bei Meltdown und Spectre
und Zeugschnitt.
Ja, meine Samsung S... Das ist eigentlich
ziemlich arm, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Ich hatte zwei...
Also genau diese zwei Sachen habe ich in meinem
neuen PC. Also mein neuer PC von
2022?
Ist schon ein Jahr, ne?
2022.
Ende 2022. Ja, genau.
Der...
Das muss man sich
echt mal überlegen. Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Mein PC ist jetzt
Ende 2022,
oder?
Oder so ist das Video.
Ich finde es echt auf...
Gut, ich mache so wenig Videos, ich kann hier einfach drüber scrollen,
dann finde ich es schon.
Ja.
So, Ende...
Geil, YouTube. Perfekt.
Ja, Ende 2022.
Und was wir alle wissen, laut YouTube,
das war vor einem Jahr. Also, Leute, vor einem Jahr
war eindeutig der 12.12.2022.
Obviously, ja.
Und da hatte ich...
Da habe ich jetzt... Da habe ich die Intel CPU drin,
die Probleme
hat. Also, eventuell
und die Samsung
SSD, die auch
firmware-updates gebraucht hat, dass sie funktioniert.
Ja.
Also, das ist schon ziemlich arm, was
Hardwarehersteller in dieser Zeit,
in diesem Zeitraum abgeliefert haben.
Muss man sich echt mal überlegen.
Jetzt, jetzt... Na gut, hey.
Ich sage nur,
4090 Kamera...
Nicht Kamera, Power...
Powerkabel, das war ja auch so ein Ding.
Überlegt
euch mal. Jetzt mal ohne Scheiß.
Die...
Die wichtigsten Komponenten so in diesem PC,
ja. Grafikkarte,
CPU, SSD,
Mainboard habe ich noch nichts gehört.
Drei davon
hatten Probleme.
Die Samsung SSD hat übelstes
Wear-Leveling-Problem gehabt,
ohne firmware-update.
Die Intel
CPU, die geht
random einfach kaputt und kackt ab.
Also, ich habe das Problem glücklicherweise
nicht, aber wer weiß, wann ich das vielleicht habe.
Ich hoffe nicht, bevor das firmware-update rauskommt.
Und die Grafikkarte hatte
Verlängerungskabel, wo der PC abfackeln kann.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß,
Mann?
Das kann doch wirklich nicht sein.
Was haben die da, was haben die da, was haben die da
gebaut, Mann? Ach ja, und der RAM
hält übrigens auch nicht das, was er verspricht,
gell? By the way.
Der RAM, der wurde ja hier verkauft als
DDR5 6400 und ich hatte den
exakt so laufen.
Auch mit diesen Timings.
Und der PC war nicht
so hundertprozentig stabil.
Und ich habe die RAM-Timings ganz normal runtergestellt
auf normales DDR5 RAM-Timing.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist. 4800, glaube ich.
Gar kein Problem.
Also vier, vier
der Dinger hatten Probleme.
Also eigentlich hatte, außer das
Mainboard, alles Probleme.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das heißt mir, das realisiere ich jetzt
gerade erst so. Das ist mir so gar nicht so aufgefallen,
weil das so alles getrennt, voneinander aufgelegt ist.
Das Ding ist eigentlich voll im Arsch.
Schon kacke, oder?
Ich meine, für voll im Arsch funktioniert der erstaunlich
problemfrei.
Was denkst du, woran das liegt, dass die Qualität nachlässt?
Okay, vielleicht
ist es einfach Zufall.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ja im Prinzip ein Trend,
den es die letzten Jahre gibt. Man guckt halt,
was das Geringste ist, was man
machen kann, dass man mit durchkommt.
Letztendlich zum Geld sparen.
Das ist nichts Neues,
aber vielleicht jetzt langsam ein bisschen
über das Ziel hinaus geschossen.
Weil das sind so
Dinger, die man ja ohne Probleme hätte
mit ordentlichem Testen feststellen können.
Also Intel ist so ein Ding, die müssen das
schon früher gewusst haben.
Samsung hätte das auch feststellen können.
Aber die machen das alle immer so,
okay, wir bringen das mal raus.
Das ist halt auch so, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem,
was hier was zugenommen hat in den letzten Jahren.
Die Hersteller wissen das,
sag ich jetzt einfach,
man kann es ihnen natürlich nicht beweisen,
die Hersteller wissen oftmals, dass es Probleme gibt,
Vermutung von mir,
sagen sich scheiß drauf, wir bringen das trotzdem raus.
Das wird schon keiner merken.
Und ich will
nicht wissen, bei wie vielen Produkten das auch tatsächlich
funktioniert, dass das einfach
keiner merkt.
Und dann komme ich mir durch.
In dem Fall, bei der Hardware war es halt schon
echt
ziemlich kacke.
Ich meine, erinnert sich noch einer da dran,
bei den neuesten
4090 Grafikkarten
mit den Verlängerungskabeln,
wo irgendwelche PCs angefangen haben zu brennen,
dann die SSD,
die irgendwie 20 mal so schnell kaputt geht
wie normal, und jetzt kommt irgendwie
ein Jahr oder eineinhalb Jahre später raus,
dass die Intel-CPUs einfach den Geist drauf geben können.
Ganz schön,
ganz schön am Arsch, oder?
Ziemlich, ziemlicher Schrott.
Okay, ich muss mal ein Start-Skript anpassen,
und zwar muss diese JetBrains-Toolbox
rein.
Warum auch immer die,
kann man die selbst updaten?
Warum auch immer
machen wir das hier raus?
Das hier rein, diese super
handliche Fahrt.
Jetzt starten wir den X-Server neu und gucken,
ob es funktioniert.
Das Problem habe ich
glücklicherweise nicht.
Ich habe kein Coil-Wine, was man zu deutsch
auch Spulenfiepe nennt.
Warum benutzt du eigentlich kein WSL?
Ich habe WSL, glaube ich, sogar installiert,
aber WSL ist mir nicht
Linux genug.
Du kannst mit WSL zum Beispiel kein
i3 benutzen, was das Beste ist.
Ich habe gehört,
von meiner alten Arbeit, ich habe letztens
mit einmal ein bisschen geschwätzt, mit einem aus
meinem ehemaligen Team,
vom alten Arbeitgeber,
und der meinte,
die sind jetzt gezwungen worden,
Windows zu installieren auf ihre Notebooks,
beziehungsweise sich ein Windows-Notebook
geben zu lassen.
Wir durften da ja früher, wir hatten ja da früher
freie Betriebssystemwahl, wir konnten auf unsere
Notebook Linux installieren. Wir müssen jetzt
ein Windows-Notebook verwenden, und
er verwendet jetzt WSL.
Und meint, WSL
geht eigentlich ganz gut.
Das ist so meine erste
höhere
Sagen-Experience, die ein bisschen neuer ist
zu WSL, ja.
Also, der meint, das geht eigentlich ganz gut mit
WSL. Sogar grafische Anwendungen würden
ganz gut gehen. Ich weiß nicht, was die da
installieren, wahrscheinlich WSLG oder sowas.
Aber komplexere grafische Anwendungen
würden nicht gescheit funktionieren.
Er hat beispielsweise versucht, da irgendein Dokument
in LibreOffice aufzumachen, und das ging nicht.
Das geb ich jetzt einfach mal
so weiter, also ich vermute jetzt mal,
ich mein, der verdient mit Linux sein Geld, ich würd
jetzt einfach mal sagen, der hat das schon richtig gemacht.
Also anscheinend gibt's tatsächlich da weiterhin
mit grafischen Anwendungen Probleme.
Natürlich kann man sich jetzt
fragen, wenn ich ne Windows-Kiste hab mit
irgendeinem Office-Abo,
warum
will ich dann was in LibreOffice aufmachen?
Aber denkt euch irgendwas anderes,
ja, aus, was ein bisschen
komplexer ist, was ihr unter Linux aufmacht.
Was dann Probleme macht.
Ich hab's selbst nicht ausprobiert, keine Ahnung.
Und ich mag, ehrlich
gesagt, auch die Trennung, so wie ich das hab.
Hier ist Windows und hier ist Linux.
Man muss halt echt mal sagen, i3 lässt sich
halt einfach um Welten,
um Längen, um Lichtjahre
besser
bedienen als Windows.
Die Windows-Suche
fängt ja schon an. Wenn ich jetzt hier mal
irgendwie nach PDF suche,
manchmal findet...
Ich mein, was zum Teufel?
Warum...
Ich fang gar nicht davon an.
Sobald Linux-Gaming reibungslos funktioniert,
bin ich weg von Windows.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich mein, wir haben die letzten Jahre über gesehen,
dass es deutlich besser geht.
Das könnte natürlich das Problem erklären,
warum manche Anwendungen damit Probleme haben.
Ich weiß nicht, kann man
unter diesem Windows Wayland
x Anwendungen laufen lassen?
Haben die quasi x
x Wayland-Kompatibilität-Zeug dabei?
Ich denke mal schon, ja.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich dann auch
komplett von Windows weg bin, weil es
sind nicht nur Games, aber Games ist natürlich
eines der größeren Sachen.
Es hat sich die letzten Jahre sehr viel getan,
was Linux-Gaming angeht.
Wir werden es aber nie
sehen, dass alles
einfach auf Linux geht.
Da geh ich nicht von aus.
Es hat sich sehr viel getan, aber so die letzten
10-15%, würde man sagen,
oder sagen wir mal, die letzten 15%,
die da noch fehlen, das sind halt auch
die Games, die unter anderem sehr viele
Leute spielen und die Probleme machen.
Also alles mit Anti-Cheat.
Oder eventuell noch ein paar andere, aber Anti-Cheat
ist so das größte Ding.
Und ich sehe es einfach nicht, dass beispielsweise
Fortnite oder so was
in die Richtung, dass die da mitziehen.
Ja, das ist das Nächste. Neben Games
sind es da noch ein paar Programme.
Wobei es dort, ganz
ehrlich, gibt es ja immer mehr Alternativen.
Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt
mehr Hoffnung dafür, dass wir
in Zukunft ordentliche Audio-Video-Bearbeitung
unter Linux machen können. Video geht ja
eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich denke mal, wenn man sich da reingedacht
hat, ist DaVinci Resolve
wahrscheinlich eines der besten
Video-Editing-Tools, die es gibt.
Und das läuft gut unter Linux.
Fotobearbeitung und sonst wie.
Also ich persönlich sehe
es früher, dass
wir ordentliche Audio-Video-Bearbeitung
unter Linux haben,
als dass Anti-Cheat-Spiele
unter Linux funktionieren.
Ja.
Also das sind tatsächlich,
und das ist halt auch das Ding,
diese zwei Sachen,
das sind seit
15 Jahren große Probleme
unter Linux,
was so die Verbreitung,
die Massenverbreitung angeht.
Was heißt Masse? Man kann auch nicht mal
wirklich Masse sagen, weil ganz ehrlich,
welche Masse der Leute
braucht wirklich Photoshop?
Ja.
Aber es gibt eine riesen Masse an Leuten,
die Fortnite spielen wollen zum Beispiel,
oder Rainbow Six, oder ich habe keine Ahnung,
was sonst noch, Apex Legends, wobei,
das geht doch mittlerweile, oder?
Geht Apex nicht mittlerweile unter Linux?
Haben die das nicht umgestellt?
Ah, weiß nicht.
Oder LOL oder sowas, ja?
Das kannst du teilweise echt knicken.
Wobei LOL
ging teilweise, aber dann auch wieder nicht.
Bei Dota weiß ich nicht, bei Valve-Sachen
ist das meistens ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Weiß nicht, wie sieht es mit CS2 unter,
unter, ähm,
unter Linux aus? Läuft das gescheit?
Okay. Ähm,
ne, nicht, wie heißt diese andere
Game, Linux, Proton,
ProtonDB meine ich, ja.
Okay, das scheint ganz brauchbar zu funktionieren.
Man braucht irgendwelche,
irgendwelche Tweaks, okay.
Ja, scheint ganz, scheint ganz
brauchbar zu funktionieren.
Aber was man bei ProtonDB
auch ganz gut sieht, ist,
die haben die Webseite umgestellt.
Es gab doch bei ProtonDB
so eine schöne Ansicht.
Geht nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Kann man das nicht mehr sortieren?
Fix Wanted?
Ah, Fix Wanted ist es jetzt.
Dann haben sie das umbenannt.
Ich bilde mir ein, das hieß früher nicht Fix Wanted.
Ja, da ist jetzt
sagen wir mal so, gut, COD kannst du auch wegen
Anti-Cheat wahrscheinlich komplett vergessen, außer
Destiny 2. Das sind halt Spiele,
die schon relativ beliebt sind, ja.
Wie Battlefield
geht auch nicht.
Ja.
Aber, na gut.
Weep Games tun auch nicht,
das ist nicht so wild. Falsch, die Mode.
Rainbow Six.
Das sind halt schon,
das sind halt schon nicht gerade
kleine Games, ja.
Also, ich denke,
bis wir die letzten 15 Prozent,
also,
auf 1000 Tera, gibt's das noch?
Lul, das hab ich mit dem Fabian mal gespielt,
vor zig Jahren.
Ja, also,
bis wir die letzten 15 Prozent Linux Gaming
sehen, glaube ich, sehen wir erst
Photoshop.
Und das werden wir auch nicht so schnell sehen.
Ja, das ist halt 15
Jahren mit die größten Probleme
und die werden es auch die nächsten 15 Jahre
sein. Auf der anderen Seite
ist sehr vieles
besser geworden und es gibt auch
mittlerweile sehr viele Alternativen
zu den etablierten Sachen.
Sowas wie DaVinci Resolve zum Beispiel.
Aber, es ist halt nicht
1 zu 1. Und das ist das, wo viele
Leute halt nicht mitmachen wollen,
wenn die wissen, okay,
ich muss mich jetzt nicht nur
betriebssystemmäßig umstellen,
ich muss mich jetzt auch anwendungsmäßig umstellen,
da haben viele Leute keinen Bock drauf.
Aus mehreren Gründen kann ich das auch verstehen, ja.
Also, wir lassen jetzt mal
die ganzen Sachen mit jemand, der damit
sein Geld verdient, weg.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nochmal ein anderer Punkt.
Aber allein schon die Umgewöhnung drumherum,
wo du vielleicht keinen Bock hast,
ja, und vielleicht
kriegst du es auch einfach alles nett hin.
Vielleicht ist es dir schlicht und ergreifend auch
zu kompliziert. Vielleicht gibt es auch keine
gescheiten Alternativen zu dem, was du machen willst.
Vielleicht hast du dich seit 15 Jahren oder so schon
an eine Bedienung gewöhnt von einem speziellen Programm
und hast
einfach keinen Bock, dich jetzt
umzugewöhnen und denkst dir, ey,
was nervt mich mehr,
Windows oder dass ich mich umgewöhnen muss
bei den Programmen? Ja, und viele
Leute, die mit
der Einstellung rangehen, so nach dem Motto,
ey, ich steig jetzt auf
Linux um,
das ist ja quasi wie Windows, bloß ohne die
Sachen, die mich nerven an Windows,
die sind halt in der Woche wieder bei Windows zurück.
Weil das ist es halt nicht.
Für meinen Anwendungszweck ist das perfekt,
wie ich das so hab, wie ich das hier
eingerichtet hab und alles.
Das ist aber nix, ich mein ernsthaft,
das, was ich hier am Start habe,
das könnte ich nicht meiner Mutter oder
sonst wem vorsetzen und sagen, hier, mach mal.
Ich mein, allein schon, wie zum Teufel
startest du hier einen Browser?
Oder wie kommst du von diesem komischen
Aquarium überhaupt zu deinem Webbrowser?
Das, guck mal,
stell dir mal vor, ja, du musst den Leuten
jetzt sagen, also als erstes
drückst du Windows-Taste 1
und um auf den ersten Desktop zu switchen,
dann drückst du Windows-Taste
D und dann machst du
Firefox, kannst du klicken. Also für mich
ist das perfekt.
Ich glaube, Noobs würden das mit einer Weile auch
hinkriegen, aber es ist halt für viele
Leute nicht wirklich praktikabel,
so wie ich es eingerichtet hab.
Also wenn, dann muss es halt
irgendwas bisschen besser Verständliches
sein, ja, also irgendwas
anderes als Arch
mit i3 vielleicht, so Linux Mint
oder sowas, genau Chat, ja.
Ey, mein Vater verwendet jetzt auch Linux Mint.
Oder auch nicht
mehr, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab von dem ne Weile nix mehr gehört.
Und das letzte,
was ich gesehen hab, ist in Teamviewer,
ich hab dem Teamviewer drauf installiert, da kann man
sehen, ob die Rechner
online sind und so. Und in Teamviewer selbst
ist der Rechner jetzt schon seit
paar Wochen nicht mehr online gewesen.
Also vielleicht
benutzt er den Rechner auch nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung. Ist mir aber
auch wurscht. Ändert sich das echt
so sehr?
Ich hab... Nee, macht er nicht.
Macht er nicht. Ich glaube, das hat sich erledigt.
Ich glaub, dass mit seiner
26-jährigen Freundin das
hat sich erledigt.
Oh man ey, was kann ich dran denken.
Also da hab ich jetzt
wenig von gemerkt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab bei Rider
so nen Keyboard-Layout,
das kann man so als Fall exportieren.
Also was sich auf jeden Fall ändert,
ist zwischen Mac, Windows und Linux.
Weil du bei Mac
die extra Command-Taste hast, die du
unter Windows nicht hast.
Er hat eine 26... Ey, Leute.
Ja, naja.
Er hat eine
26-jährige Freundin
aus so nem dritten Weltland, irgendwo
in der Karibik, Südamerika.
Und der überweist da halt regelmäßig
Geld hin. Und
deswegen erzählt die ihm halt, dass sie ihn geil und
toll findet. Es ist nicht so, als hätte
mein Vater wahnsinnig viel Geld. Das ist eher
das Gegenteil der Fall. Der muss mich
sogar öfters mal anpuppen, zumindest in der Vergangenheit.
Aber
er hat genug Rente,
um
ab und zu mal ein bisschen was
überweisen zu können.
Was für unsere Verhältnisse
nicht viel Geld ist.
Und dort halt
schon ein bisschen was.
Dazu kommt,
der war angeblich auch schon da
und hat da Urlaub gemacht.
Ja, also zumindest
die auf den Bildern scheint es zu geben.
Ob die das ist, die dann tagsüber mit dem schreibt,
keine Ahnung. Ich hab ihm auch schon gesagt,
meinst du nicht, dass das Scam ist?
Und er denkt, die finden ihn wirklich toll.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab's ihm versucht auszureden,
aber man kann's die Leute nicht vor sich selbst beschützen.
Ja, und
da überweist er.
Ich mein, ganz im Ernst,
die hat wahrscheinlich fünf oder
sechs Typen, mit denen sie das so macht.
Und dann kommt da ein bisschen Kohle für die zusammen.
Ich find's ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal
sonderlich schlimm, wenn
das beide Seiten quasi so im...
Wenn das beide Seiten wissen,
ja. Wenn die sich
sagt, ey,
so toll find ich die ganzen alten Säcke aus Deutschland
jetzt nicht, aber bringt Geld
und die wissen, okay,
die setzt sich auch nur mit
mir auseinander, weil ich regelmäßig
Geld überweise, ist das
denke ich in Ordnung.
Aber mein Vater sieht's halt
nicht so ein. Der denkt halt, die finden ihn wirklich toll.
Aber soll er's denken? Ich mein, was...
Es ist ja nicht schlimm,
dass er das denkt. Viel blöder ist,
dass er ab und zu da Kohle hin überweist.
Ja, ja. Aber ich glaub, das hat sich
jetzt erledigt. Ich glaub, das hat sich erledigt.
Ja. Der war letztens noch mal im
Krankenhaus und dann hat er sich...
Ich glaube, der hat jetzt andere Probleme, als
da mit
der Zeug zu schreiben und Geld zu überweisen.
Oh, Mann.
Mediamarkt?
Was? Also ich würd mich...
Der letzte Laden, in dem ich mich beraten
lassen würde, ist ein Mediamarkt.
Da würd ich lieber selbst irgendwie mal auf Reddit
lesen, was für mich sinnvoll ist.
Also...
Mediamarkt ist genauso
wie Saturn. Das ist ja der gleiche Laden. Oder ist es
das noch? Früher war's das zumindest.
Kannste vergessen, ne?
Da war's früher auch schon.
Gleiche... War im Prinzip der gleiche Laden.
Die haben in der Werbung immer so getan, so
als sind die da gegeneinander und
Mediamarkt hat bessere Preise und wir haben
jetzt bessere und jetzt wir schlagen das. Dabei war
das der gleiche Laden schon immer.
Mikrocenter hab ich noch nie gehört.
Bei den Amis kenn ich nur Walmart.
Und die verkaufen
wahrscheinlich... Wobei, die verkaufen wahrscheinlich auch Notebooks.
Keine Ahnung.
In meiner VM-Welt
nicht.
Wie heißt die Suchleiste? Du meinst das da?
Das ist nicht nur Apps.
Das kann auch
Emojis suchen.
Meine Zwischenablage durchsuchen.
Und ein paar Sachen ausführen.
Das heißt... Genau. Der Chat
ist schon schneller als ich.
Genau so heißt das.
Findest du auf... Das da.
Recht beliebt.
13.000 Sterne.
Lass uns mal gucken, was trendet auf Shithub.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal die Beratung ausprobiert?
Geht um ein Low-End-Laptop.
20 Jahre.
Oder so.
Länger. 25 Jahre.
Wie gut funktioniert 4K
beziehungsweise Ultra-Weizgemonitore mittlerweile
in Linux? Du meinst jetzt wegen
High-DPI.
Das hängt ein bisschen von deinem Desktop-Environment ab.
Und was du da so für Einstellungen machen kannst.
Was ich gesehen habe ist,
dass es mittlerweile unter
Linux Mint
wenn du
die passende Grafikkartentreiber hast
dass es mittlerweile
ordentliches Scaling
beziehungsweise DPI-Settings gibt.
Wie ich das hier machen würde
wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Ich müsste das wahrscheinlich
irgendwie selbst setzen.
Wie gut es mit Wayland geht
habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich würde mal vermuten besser als mit X.
Einfach weil das neuer ist.
Leute, wie ist es so
mit High-DPI-Displays
und hochauflösenden Displays mit Wayland?
Das ist doch bestimmt besser als unter X, oder?
Ich habe das noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich würde einfach mal von
ausgehen, dass es besser ist.
Wobei bei Wayland ist ja immer die Frage
ist es allgemein besser
oder ist es halt
bei manchen besser, weil in Wayland musst du ja sehr viel selbst
bauen. Also da baut ja dann
KDE was anderes wie Gnome, was anderes
wie Sway, was anderes wie Hyper und so.
Ich habe auch nur 1080p.
monitor.
Das liegt daran, weil es ein 240Hz-Monitor
ist und wir aktuell zumindest
mehr FPS, bzw. FPS ist ja
nicht gleich Hertz, aber mehr Wiederholrate und
hohe FPS zusammen noch wichtiger
sind als höhere Auflösung.
Was ich gerne hätte ist
ein hochauflösendes
OLED-Display
mit 240
oder sagen wir so mit hoher
Bildwiederholfrequenz.
Das gibt es,
aber
die Dinger sind teilweise schweineteuer
und noch ein bisschen
verbesserungswürdig. Es gab sogar Monitore,
die hatten Lüfter drinnen, weil sie es sonst nicht
auf die Reihe gekriegt haben. Und ganz ehrlich
Lüfter in Monitoren
irgendwann ist auch mal gut.
Ja, stimmt. Und du hast theoretisch
die Möglichkeit, dass es einbrennt. Wie sehr
das wirklich noch ein Problem ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Erstmal kurz gucken, was hier auf
Shithub trendet. Was soll das sein?
Dafür braucht man eine eigene
Verwaltungssoftware.
Ich habe genau eine Filamentrolle.
Eine weiße Filamentrolle.
Das war's. Und damit
drucke ich mein Zeug, wenn ich mal was drucke.
Aber ich gebe zu, ich benutze das
auch nicht sonderlich professional, meinen 3D-Drucker.
Eine Filamentrolle.
Und die muss ich tatsächlich bald
mal austauschen. Da ist nicht mehr so viel drauf.
Aber die hat jetzt drei Jahre oder wie lange
ich den Drucker habe gehalten. Oder wie lange
habe ich den Drucker schon? Den hatte ich schon vor Corona.
Vier Jahre vielleicht sogar.
Das ist halt
das wäre mir persönlich
viel zu groß für den Schreibtisch.
Ich sitze aber auch nah
davor. Riesenfettes
Ding.
Hat 240
Hertz. Was ist denn das überhaupt
für eine Auflösung? 5120
mal 1000. DQHD.
Okay,
WQHD ist aus. DQHD haben wir
jetzt. WQHD
ist outdated, overrated, cheapated.
Wir machen jetzt
DQHD.
Kostet?
1000 Euro.
Ich meine, ich würde sagen
geht noch irgendwo klar für so ein Ding.
Ach, hier sind
noch die letzten Stellenanzeigen.
Muss man auch noch irgendwann mal fertig machen.
Lass mal schauen, was auf Shithub so trendet.
Memo. AI.
Okay, skip.
Nee, das ist nicht AI.
Open GPU Kernel Modules.
Ja, das habe ich auch gelesen, dass Nvidia
ihre GPU-Treiber jetzt angeblich
endlich open sourced, aber dann doch wieder
irgendwie nicht alles. Das ist,
ich weiß auch nicht, warum die so einen Hickhack drumherum
machen, Alter. Könnte ich einfach sagen,
ey, hier ist das komplett Gutes.
Juckt nicht, juckt nicht.
Juckt nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das sein soll. Was ist das?
Also die Beschreibung ist auch wieder so
nichtssagend. AI, okay.
AI, AI,
AI, AI. Nee, nicht wirklich AI.
Okay, nicht sonderlich spannend
diese Woche, was
da trendet. Zumindest
ist es nicht viermal AI.
Plötzchen.
Lösch den Satz.
Zum Glück ist es nicht nur AI.
LZ4 trendet.
Okay, random, dass LZ4 trendet.
C++ MonkaS.
Nicht so spannend.
Übrigens,
ich habe in den letzten Tagen wieder ein bisschen
Offscreen, noch ein bisschen C++ programmiert
und mir sind wieder Sachen aufgefallen, Leute.
Wie kommst du jetzt da drauf?
Ich wollte mich gerade ein bisschen über C++ auskotzen.
Ah, okay, deswegen trendet das.
Ach so.
Und
da ist mir mal wieder was aufgefallen bei C++,
was extrem
weird ist. Und zwar
man kann in C++
zur Compile-Zeit checken,
ob man
einen Typ dem anderen zuweisen kann
und wenn nicht, dann halt nicht.
So, und da gibt es
und da wird es jetzt lustig
und zwar
ist das Beispiel hier, guck mal.
Is
inassignable
from int
wouldn't compile.
Natürlich, ein int zuweisen
ist obviously natürlich ein Fehler.
Aber,
aber,
einen Double, einen String zuweisen,
das ist okay.
Ich weiß, warum es, bevor jetzt jemand ankommt,
Max, das ist aber doch so und so.
Ich weiß, warum es so ist.
Aber warum designen die Sachen in dieser Sprache
so, dass es auf den ersten Blick
komplett missverständlich,
unverständlich und für den Arsch ist?
Ich meine, warum
denkt man, dass
isassignable int int ein Fehler ist,
aber isassignable
string int geht?
Int zu einem int sollte
das, das, das
naheliegendste und offensichtlichste überhaupt sein.
Ist es aber nicht. Guck,
int isassignable from int false.
String isassignable from double true.
Wobei das, wobei das
gar nicht funktioniert, aber
das schon.
Und ausgerechnet das geht angeblich
nicht und das geht.
Diese Sprache ist einfach ein Fass
ohne Boden der dämlichen
Sachen. Ich habe Mitleid
mit den Leuten. Also, ich habe Mitleid
mit den Leuten, die C++ machen müssen,
weil es irgendwie nicht
drumherum kommt.
Ich habe
wenig Verständnis für die Leute,
die freiwillig
C++ machen, obwohl
es was anderes gäbe.
Also, ohne dass es jetzt irgendeinen Vorteil
hätte.
Ist damit gemeint, dass man
einem int kein int
zuweisen kann. Damit ist gemeint,
dass, okay,
wo war das?
Was damit gemeint ist,
dass du,
was damit gemeint ist, dass du,
genau, richtig,
es ist das, was
du gesagt hast. Du kannst einem int
kein int
zuweisen, genau. Du kannst
aber eine int Variable
ein int zuweisen,
eine Zahl zuweisen. Das funktioniert.
Das Ding ist bloß,
dass das halt wieder, warum ist
das so gemacht? So, dass es halt
auf den ersten Blick schon wieder dumm aussieht,
ja? Also,
was damit gemeint ist,
also, du kannst,
du kannst nicht sagen, zum Beispiel,
hier,
1 gleich 2, oder 1, 2,
das geht nicht. Was du sagen
kannst, ist int a gleich 3.
So, das funktioniert. Deswegen geht
deswegen ist das hier false
und das hier true, weil du dann noch
und an das int hinten dran machst und dann
ist das wie, wenn du eine Variable verwendest.
Was aber viel witziger ist,
das hier
funktioniert nicht.
Aber, das ist auch so ein Ding,
jetzt, Leute, passt mal auf,
runde kecken,
ich zeige euch das,
runde keck w,
also,
standard
string, blub,
gleich 1, geht nicht.
Funktioniert nicht, ne?
Und jetzt ist die Frage, Chat, was meint
ihr?
Funktioniert das?
Das funktioniert.
Ich kann euch auch erklären, warum.
Es ergibt sogar Sinn, aber es ist einfach
so hängen geblieben.
Es ist einfach so hängen geblieben,
dass das so ist, ne?
Chat, wer weiß, warum das funktioniert?
Wird 5 als
String verwendet? Nein, wird's nicht.
Ich kann's euch erklären, es ist,
nach der Erklärung ist
es irgendwie, aber es ist einfach massiv
dämlich.
Also, wir halten fest, in C++
ist, ja,
das hier ist verboten,
aber,
das hier ist erlaubt.
Okay? Alles klar?
Also,
kaputt,
geht.
Und warum ist das so?
Man würde sich jetzt denken, ey,
eigentlich ist es ja kein so großer
Unterschied, ne? Aber doch,
ist es.
Es liegt daran,
weil,
also,
ich erklär euch erstmal die abstrakte
Variante, warum das so ist.
Wenn du so zuweist, ist das
quasi das Gleiche, wenn du so sagst.
Das ist impliziter Cast zu Character.
Und,
ich glaube, die C++-Erklärung
ist, dass
das Standard-String
kein
Copy-Constructor, oder wie das heißt,
hat, der ein Int,
beziehungsweise ein Character akzeptiert.
Aber,
Standard-String hat einen überschriebenen
Assignment-Operator,
der
Character akzeptiert. Deswegen
geht das hier,
und das hier nicht.
Das sind aber halt auch so Dinge, ganz ehrlich,
warum baut man das überhaupt
so? Also, warum
designt man eine Sprache,
um Ausnahmefälle immer drum herum?
Das ist auch so ein Ding,
was ich an C++ immer nicht verstehe.
Warum machen die Sachen, die
nach einer Erklärung zwar logisch sind,
aber erstmal unintuitiv
und widersprüchlich sind? Das ist so,
echt für den Arsch.
Da gibt es noch mehr so Dinge, und das checkt man
halt einfach nicht. Und das Problem ist
nicht, dass es ein paar Dinge gibt, ja?
In .NET und in C Sharp, oder in Go,
oder in Rust, du hast da auch so
einzelne Dinge, müsste ich mir jetzt mal
Gedanken drüber machen, wo du dir so denkst, ey,
muss das echt sein? Oh, das ist ja schon
ein bisschen unverständlich. Aber in
C++ ist es so, dass im Prinzip die
Sprache eine riesen Ansammlung
aus unlogischen, unverständlichen,
ja,
einfach misszuinterpretierenden
Konstrukten ist,
und die halt
alle in einen Sack geschmissen.
Bestimmt, bestimmt ist das irgendein Legacy,
garantiert, garantiert ist das irgendein Legacy,
100 pro.
Also, ich bin da mal
der Meinung, wenn man C++ besser machen möchte,
auf einen Schlag besser
machen möchte, wären
Extension
Methods, das wäre wirklich mega
nice, wenn das gehen würde.
Stellt euch mal vor,
wir könnten
Standard
Standard String erweitern,
um eigene Methoden.
Das wäre halt mega nice, ja?
Zum Beispiel könnte ich dann sowas machen, wie
Repeat,
oder sowas, oder Sachen, die es nicht gibt.
Aktuell musst du immer
das alles in irgendwelche Methoden rappen,
das ist halt eklig, das sieht ein bisschen so aus, wie in Go.
Also Extension Methods würde das
Ganze um ein Vielfaches besser machen, aus
meiner Sicht, oder ein paar andere
Dinger, aber ehrlich gesagt müssen
die erst, müssten die erst mal anfangen,
die Sprache nicht noch mit jedem
Standard
inkonsistenter zu machen.
Ja.
Ich kenne mich nicht gut mit C++ aus.
Ich kenne mich mit
C++ nur so weit aus, wie es
mein Microcontroller-Gebastel erfordert.
Gut auskennen tue ich mich
damit nicht.
Kannst du etwas zur C++ Meta...
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst, du meinst irgendwelche
3000 in sich geschachtelten
Templates mit
Concepts und
If-Dings, Constraints
und sonst was, da kann ich nichts zu sagen, das habe ich selbst noch nie
gemacht. Das höchste
der Gefühle, was ich gemacht habe, ist glaube ich mal
ein Template,
was zur Laufzeit
checkt, ob man das
Argument, ne, ne, ne, nicht zur Laufzeit, was zur
Compile-Zeit checkt,
ob man das Argument in
int64 konvertieren
kann und sowas. Das ist aber echt das höchste
der Gefühle. Du kannst ganz abgedrehte
Sachen machen.
Letztendlich muss man aber auch sagen,
dass
das nicht gut funktioniert in
C++, ja. Wenn man sich
das, also so generelle, nennen wir es mal
Meta-Programmierung,
weil dazu bräuchtest du irgendeine
ordentliche Art von Reflection
und das gibt es in C++ nicht. Es gibt
so selbst gehackte Dinger
mit irgendwelchen Compiler-Magics
und durch
die Brust ins Auge
halbes Undefined
Behaviour, was dann doch wieder geht,
aber nachdem C++
keinerlei Möglichkeiten von
Reflection hat,
ist das schwierig.
Also Reflection heißt
in dem Fall, dass man zur Laufzeit oder zumindest
zur Compile-Zeit
quasi
Infos über das eigene Programm abfragen
kann. Zum Beispiel,
dass man
abfragen kann, ist das
Argument eine Klasse oder ein Instruct
oder was ist das?
Und dass du
wobei das
geht in C++.
Was ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür?
Ja,
zum Beispiel,
dass du zur Compile-Zeit checken kannst,
ist es ein Int oder
ist es ein Inam. Das geht in C++
nicht.
Es gibt zwar 3-4 verschiedene Möglichkeiten
einen Inam zu definieren, aber das
konvertiert alles zu einem Int.
Also du kannst nicht checken,
ist das
ein spezieller
Inam-Type. Das geht
jetzt gerade in Ansätzen
seit C++
23, aber auch
nicht richtig. Also kannst du zum Beispiel
auch nicht sagen,
jedes Mal, wenn ein Template
oder wenn ein Typ angelegt wird,
zählst du einen Counter automatisch hoch,
dass du da irgendwas im Hintergrund verknüpfe.
Also, das geht in C++ nicht gescheit.
Wenn du das mal mit beispielsweise
Reflections vergleichst in .NET, ist das
einfach ein Riesenunterschied.
Ja, in .NET
kannst du beispielsweise sagen, okay,
ich suche alle Klassen,
das ist übrigens ein gutes Beispiel für Reflection,
die, also
könntest du machen,
ich suche alle Klassen,
die eine Methode enthalten
mit dem Namen Blub
und ein Int als
ersten Parameter akzeptieren.
Das kannst du in C Sharp machen und dann
kriegst du das. Was du dann mit der Information
machst, sei mal wieder dahingestellt, aber das geht.
Das ist so Sachen, das ist in C++ nicht möglich.
Ja, die werden es
sicherlich schaffen, noch verwirrender zu machen,
gehe ich stark von aus.
So, aber eigentlich wollte ich jetzt
gar nicht
freuen.
Ja, lange nicht gesehen, der Name
sagt mir noch was. Aber wie gesagt,
ich habe davon nicht wirklich viel Ahnung.
Ich beschäftige mich da immer nur
so phasenweise
damit,
immer wenn ich mal irgendwelche
Microcontroller-Sachen bastle und
ich habe eine riesenlange Liste, warum
C++ sackt mit solchen Beispielen
drinnen.
Und es wird einfach
mehr. Man würde
immer mehr, man würde
eigentlich denken, das ist irgendwann mal erschöpft,
ja? Irgendwann hat man allen Bullshit
mal gesehen, aber C++ ist
da ein Fass ohne Boden. Je mehr du damit
machst, je mehr Bullshit fällt dir auf.
Eine UI in der Standardlibrary?
Ne.
Die C++-Standardlibrary ist eh Shit.
Und nicht, weil sie keine
UILibrary dabei haben. Das gibt
verschiedenste.
Du kannst natürlich auch mit
C++ die native UIRP deines
Betriebssystems verwenden.
Was unter Linux nicht gibt, aber
du kannst unter Windows, kannst du Windows Forms
machen mit C++, Alter.
Weil ist das
irgendjemand...
Die ist gar nicht expired.
Wo bloß, warum haben wir noch so viele?
Das muss sich auch ändern.
Das, das...
Die Domain, die benutzen wir schon ewig
nicht mehr.
Das muss alles wo bloß...
Nightbot...
Custom...
Ähm...
Wo macht man das hier unter Nightbot?
Wo stellt man beim Nightbot
ein, dass der regelmäßig was
schreibt?
Default...
Hm... Timers.
Submit. Okay.
Ja, die hat...
Die Domain hat glaube ich der Sebarro noch.
So. Okay.
Ich wollte gerade mal kurz gucken...
Ich wollte gerade mal kurz schauen,
ob ich die Domain vielleicht nicht doch habe.
Und das nur vergessen hab.
Ähm... Muss ich mich aber einloggen.
Ich hab...
Ich hab den
dümmsten Fake-Namen überhaupt
bei diesem Domain-Registrar, Alter.
Verification-Code...
Oh Gott, jetzt krieg ich das...
Muss ich mich auch noch bei gmx einloggen.
Und Verification-Code eingeben.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Oh Mann, Alter.
Das dauert jetzt kurz ne Minute.
Jetzt muss ich noch zwei
Faktor-Authentifizierung machen, Mann.
Hört der echt nicht mehr auf?
Bitte
geben Sie den zwei Faktor-Code an.
Ihre Sitzung ist abgelaufen.
Boah! Ey, ist das ja grausam
gerade!
Ich will doch einfach nur...
gucken, was meine Domain
macht. Und nicht
aus versehen irgendwelche Passwörter copy-pasten
in den Chat nebenbei.
Okay, zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Okay. Ich glaube, ich hab's.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Alles, alles, alles.
Ja, ja.
Jetzt brauch ich den Confirmation-Code
für das Login auf der...
Ey, das ist ja...
Du hast ja schnell eine
Weltreise gemacht, bevor du dich hier einloggen
darfst.
Okay. Ich glaube, ich hab's geschafft. So.
Reject. Ne.
Max.tv haben wir gar nicht mehr.
Ich hab MaxFPS.tv
und Wublos.tv.
Dass wir jemals Max.tv hatten,
keine Ahnung. Das hatte der Sibaro noch
wahrscheinlich. Und irgendeine
Url-Weiterleitung gemacht. Das müssen wir alle...
Das muss ich theoretisch
bei allen Commands, wo das
drinnen steht... Ja, gibt's
ja nicht so viel.
Das ist, glaube ich... Max.tv war, glaube ich, ein
Url-Shortener, den der Sibaro mal
angelegt hat.
Das muss ich alles austauschen.
Das muss ich alles austauschen. Das sind zum Glück
nur vier Commands.
Ja. Okay.
Was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gucken? Ne, genau. Also, wie gesagt,
die Domain hab ich nicht.
Das Passkey ist ordentlich. Pff, keine Ahnung.
Kann ich schlecht einschätzen.
Keine Ahnung. So.
Okay. Dann lasst uns mal
das Video angucken hier.
Was der Auer...
Also, das wollte ich mir nämlich
wirklich mal zu Gemüte führen, weil
ich hab das nicht so richtig verstanden.
Welche CPUs... Wir gucken mal erst
im Schnelldurchlauf an,
was der Bauer dazu zu sagen hat, zu der
aktuellen Intel
CPU-Problematik.
Der Auer.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem
weiteren Video. Ihr habt es mit Sicherheit
in letzter Zeit mitbekommen, dass Intel schon
seit längerem Probleme mit der 13.
und 14. Generation hat,
dass die CPUs... Ja, das hab ich mitbekommen,
aber durchblicken tu ich trotzdem nicht.
...stabil sind. Und das ist jetzt schon was,
was sich über Monate hinzieht. Ja.
Teilweise schon seit über einem Jahr.
Und ich hab mittlerweile auch immer wieder Kommentare
dazu bekommen, warum ich nichts zu diesem Thema mache.
Der Grund war ganz einfach, ich hatte
einfach nichts Sinnvolles zu diesem Thema
beizutragen. Ich hab das tatsächlich
schon relativ früh mitbekommen, vor
circa einem halben Jahr, dass mich ein paar
Leute angeschrieben haben hinsichtlich
Stabilitätsprobleme bei den 14.
Generationen CPUs.
Jetzt ist allerdings immer die Sache, aus meiner Position
frage ich mich dann, was mache
ich mit dieser Information? Selbst
wenn ich weiß... Intel schlecht machen.
...stabil sind, kann ich dadurch erstmal nicht...
Intel flamen. Intel flamen ist immer
die richtige Reaktion.
...wirklich irgendwas Sinnvolles
beitragen. Also ich kann dann vielleicht selbst die CPU
organisieren und testen und dann sagen, okay, die CPU
ist instabil. Dann sagt Intel,
okay, die CPU hat vielleicht ein Problem,
schickt die zurück und wir tauschen die aus.
Und deswegen hab ich einfach dazu
nichts gemacht und hab abgewartet. Mittlerweile hat sich
sehr, sehr viel getan.
Ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall die letzten
zwei Gamers Nexus Videos
zu diesem Thema anzuschauen. Die werde ich euch auch unten
verlinken. Da bekommt ihr nochmal
viele weitere Informationen.
Ich hab so ein paar technische Hintergründe...
Meines Wissens nach ist 14. und
13. Generation die Dinger, die
13.000 irgendwas heißen und 14.000
irgendetwas heißen.
...die ich zu der Oxidation sagen will und
generell zu den Stabilitätsproblemen
und was ich davon halte, jetzt auch
wo wir von Intel bestätigt
bekommen haben, was die Probleme sind
und wie ich das Ganze auffasse und
wo ich da tatsächlich noch große Probleme sehe.
Die Probleme haben sich in der letzten Zeit
eben gehäuft und das Problem war, dass es
nicht nur eine CPU... Also was ich halt
nicht checke und was ich jetzt hoffe, dass es...
Ob man irgendwo gucken kann,
ob jetzt die CPU,
wenn in dieser Zeit gefertigt wurde, betroffen ist,
oder nicht, weil ich hab potenziell einen.
Ich hab einen der ersten
13.900K. Ich vermute mal,
der ist prinzipiell schon betroffen,
aber so richtig wissen, nachgucken kann man
ja nicht.
...CPUs, sowohl 13. als auch 14. Generation
und auch in ganz vielen unterschiedlichen
Szenarien, was dann eben die Fehlersuche
umso schwieriger macht. Und ich kann mir auch
vorstellen, dass selbst für Intel so eine
Fehlersuche, wenn man erstmal nicht weiß,
wonach man eigentlich sucht... Das ist nicht easy,
das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Und jetzt wissen wir allerdings, dass es
zwei Probleme gibt. Das eine Problem,
oder Probleme gab. Das eine Problem ist
die Oxidation, von der
auch Gamers Nexus Steve berichtet hat.
Das betrifft laut Intel allerdings nur
nen frühen Anteil
von Intel 13. Generation...
Nice! Also genau meine! Yeah!
Early Intel Core 13th Gen.
Ja, hab ich. Ich hab
mir 2000...
Dezember 2022
9900K gekauft.
Das wurde in 2023 gefixt. Jawoll!
Ja, es war meine CPU wahrscheinlich
im Arsch. Geil! Aber
es ist auch... Hier und hier schreiben sie aber,
es ist manche,
manche
Rühen... Also es kann auch sein,
dass meiner Milch betroffen ist.
...und auch aus letztem Jahr. Was
diese Oxidation betrifft, das möchte ich
ganz kurz erklären. Und zwar betrifft
es die sogenannte VIA
Oxidation. VIA ist ne
Durchkontaktierung von der CPU.
Diese VIAs, und ich werd auch beim englischen Begriff
bleiben, weil es geläufiger ist in der Branche als
ne Durchkontaktierung, die ist eben dafür da, um
die verschiedenen Ebenen von der CPU miteinander
zu verbinden. Bei ner aktuellen Intel 7
CPU, also zum Beispiel 14900K,
haben wir ungefähr 15
Ebenen, die miteinander verbunden werden
müssen. Ganz unten ist der Silizium Wafer
und darauf aufgebaut wird eben...
Ich bin froh, dass ich immer
zwei PCs am Start hab.
Dass ich nicht zwei Monitore
am gleichen PC hab, sondern
zwei PCs mit jeweils einem Monitor.
Weil, sollte einer abkacken bei mir,
hab ich immer noch den zweiten.
Also ich hab immer meinen aktuellen
PC und den davor.
Und der davor, der kommt dann auf den Dachboden
oder so.
Also ich hab immer noch den,
den ich davor hatte. Das heißt, wenn
wirklich mein Rechner jetzt einfach mal
den Geist aufgibt, dann
SSD und so, das geht ja alles noch.
Das kann ich dann theoretisch einfach an den anderen stöpseln
und dann funzt das.
Also
da hab ich immer noch
die Möglichkeit, relativ schnell
zu swappen.
Weil das wär echt kacke. Stell dir mal vor,
ich sag, oh ja, gut, machen wir hier
morgens Rechner an, Homeoffice starten
und dann geht der Rechner nicht an, weil die CPU im Arsch ist.
Ziemlich kacke, ja?
Und das wird dann von ganz, ganz klein
zu immer, immer größer. Und das ist
dann eben sowohl für die Datenverbindung
als auch für die Stromzufuhr
von der CPU, von den einzelnen Bereichen
eben wichtig, dass man das dann immer
feiner runter verteilt, bis man eben von oben
zum Beispiel von den 1700 Pins
von einem
14.900K zu den Milliarden
an Transistoren kommt. Rechner geht nicht mal an?
Also, würde ich schon sagen, dass das passieren kann.
Also, es äußert sich ja in zwei Arten, die Dinger
werden immer instabiler oder sie gehen halt
irgendwann gar nicht. Und hier geht's ja anscheinend wirklich um ein
Fertigungsproblem, wo dann irgendwelche Kontakte
miteinander, wo dann Sachen, Teile der
CPU Kontakt zueinander haben,
die sie nicht haben sollten. Dann würde ich sagen, geht der Rechner nicht mehr an.
Weil du Pech hast.
Und die dann miteinander verschaltet werden müssen.
Und dafür sind eben diese
Tiers wichtig.
Und normalerweise besteht der Großteil
von so einer CPU, die verschiedenen
Metalllayer, die dann eben die
Verschaltung darstellen, bestehen aus Kupfer.
Beim 14.900K ist es ein bisschen
spezieller, dass die ganz unteren Schichten,
die ganz feinen, die dann zu den Transistoren gehen,
auch noch aus Kobalt bestehen.
Und ich habe ja gar kein 14.000.
Weil es für den Fall eigentlich keine wirkliche Rolle spielt.
Hätte ich mir doch mal eine AMD-Kiste gekauft.
Wenn man jetzt so eine CPU
herstellt, dann wird die, wie gesagt, in Schichten
aufgebaut. Das heißt, sie haben unten die Transistoren und dann
fängt man an, eben die erste Kupferschicht zu machen,
um die Transistoren miteinander zu verbinden.
Und jetzt kommt eben dieses Thema, wo Intel
gesagt hat, bei diesen VIAs gibt es eine
Oxidation oder gab es eine Oxidation bei der
13. Generation, die zu Problemen
geführt hat. Und jetzt muss man wissen,
dass wenn man so ein VIA herstellt, also so eine
Durchkontaktierung zwischen zwei Ebenen,
dann ist es einfach so, ihr habt ja unten
drunter, in der untersten Ebene, habt ihr bereits Kupfer.
Darauf wird Silizium
abgeschieden. Und durch
dieses Silizium wollen wir jetzt quasi ein Loch bohren,
um dann eine Verbindung nach unten her
zu stellen. Das passiert erstmal Fotolacken drüber,
dann wird eben ein Loch geätzt,
das kann auch ein Graben sein, wenn da eine längere
Leiterbahn zum Beispiel verläuft.
IIQ CPU Fertigungstalk.
Und dann ist es so, dass
nach dem Ätzen dann
die Schicht erstmal isoliert werden
muss. Also das Kupfer darf keinen
direkten Kontakt mit dem Silizium herstellen,
deswegen wird als erstes... Jetzt können wir
das, also nach der Erklärung können wir das selbst machen,
oder? Bisschen Nagellack
drauf, dann
so ein kleines Loch
rein, easy. Eine Isolierschicht
aufgebracht auf... Ja, vielleicht
Chat, vielleicht brauchen
wir eine Lupe dafür, aber ansonsten kein
Ding. Kann dann zum Beispiel Silizium
Dioxid sein oder Siliziumnitrit
und darauf kommt nochmal eine zusätzliche
Schicht, das ist normalerweise Tantalnitrit
und das wird dann benutzt,
dass das Kupfer darauf
auch haften kann und gleichzeitig ist
das eine Diffusionssperre,
dass das Kupfer auch da bleibt, wo es ist
und nirgends anders hingeht. Das heißt, wir haben also
Silizium, dann Schicht
Siliziumoxid, dann Tantalnitrit und
darauf kann dann... Ist so ein Nanometer groß,
ja deswegen sage ich ja eine Lupe vielleicht,
aber ansonsten easy.
...werden in einer ersten ziemlich dünnen Schicht,
das macht man mit Atomic Layer Deposition
nennt sich das. Alter. Das ist ein spezifisches
Verfahren, mit dem unterschiedliche
Metalle quasi auf atomarer
Ebene perfekt präzise...
Ja, eine Lupe, sage ich doch. ...hergestellt werden
können. Reicht. Bei dem ALD
Verfahren, wenn wir Kupfer abscheiden wollen, haben wir
einen Grundstoff, der Kupfer enthält und wir brauchen
ein Reduktionsmittel... Alter, Moment,
wo sind wir
jetzt dabei?
Das kann zum Beispiel Wasserstoff sein
oder Plasma... Das ist mir zu high
IQ für morgen schon. ...dass das Kupfer in einer
atomardünnen Schicht ganz
präzise abgeschieden wird.
Und jetzt darf man eben nicht vergessen... Das heißt abgeschieden
und nicht ausgeschieden werden. ...dass wenn das alles gemacht wird, wird da ja schon
eine Schicht Kupfer... Also, was ich
jetzt verstehe ist,
dass dann irgendwelche Ebenen in der CPU
miteinander Kontakt haben, die sie nicht haben sollten.
Wir haben Kupfer und
ein Loch, wo wir Kupfer drin abscheiden wollen.
Das innen dann beschichtet ist
und wenn man jetzt hier sowas macht,
wie dann eben mit diesem Plasma abscheiden,
also dieses ALD Verfahren, wo Plasma
eingesetzt wird, dann kann das
dazu führen, je nachdem welcher Grundstoff da
verwendet wird, dass das Kupfer,
was unten drunter ist, teilweise
oxidiert, weil da
sind unterschiedliche Schritte, unterschiedliche
Prozessschritte, die gemacht werden.
Da kann auch Gas mit dabei
sein, wie CO2, da kann auch Wasser mit dabei
sein und gerade wenn Plasma mit dazu kommt,
hohe Temperaturen, dann kann das auch dazu
kommen, dass dann zum Beispiel Wasser aufgespaltet wird.
Der Bauer hat mich komplett abgehängt.
Ich habe absolut keinen plassen Schimmer mehr,
um was es geht.
Spaltet wird in Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff
und dann kommt es zu einer Oxidation
von Kupfer und das kann dann halt auch wirklich
nur an ganz winzigen kleinen Stellen sein,
weil wir reden hier ja meistens von
Leiterbahnen, von VIAs,
die sind wenige Nanometer groß, also
10, 20, 30 Nanometer sowas in der Richtung
und da ist es dann halt schon relevant,
wenn dann ein paar Sauerstoffatome
dann an eine Stelle kommen und dann
vielleicht schon eine Durchkontaktierung
beeinflussen und Oxidation
Ich habe jetzt nur verstanden, ich will nicht, dass
meine CPU das macht.
beschreibt dann eben ganz vereinfacht
die Interaktion zwischen Kupfer,
also die Reaktion von Kupfer mit
Sauerstoff und das kostet dementsprechend
Kupfer, was eigentlich sehr, sehr gut
leiten soll, dann zum Beispiel zu
Kupferoxid oder Kupferdioxid wird,
was viel, viel schlechter leitet als
normales Kupfer und dementsprechend
dann eben die Signalintegrität von
der CPU von dieser spezifischen Leiterbahn
dann deutlich beeinflussen wird.
Und um jetzt einschätzen zu können, warum
das mit der Oxidation überhaupt relevant ist
für die Alterung, kommen wir
zu Elektromigration, das kennen
viele, das ist einfach ein Phänomen,
das bei jeder CPU immer passiert
und was letztendlich immer dazu führt, dass
jede CPU irgendwann stirbt.
Ok, in der Theorie,
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich kann
mich nicht daran erinnern, dass ich irgendwann mal
eine CPU hatte, die an
Altersschwäche gestorben ist.
Ich glaube, mir ist noch nie, ich weiß nicht, wie sieht es bei euch aus,
Leute, ich glaube, mir ist
noch nie wirklich eine
CPU jemals kaputt gegangen.
Also im Privaten
jetzt, ja, also bei irgendwelchen
Servern im Rechenzentrum oder so haben wir sicherlich schon mal
CPUs ausgetauscht,
wenn ich mich jetzt an keinen Fall erinnern kann,
aber im Privaten ist mir noch nie
eine CPU kaputt gegangen
und ich weiß, ich habe
bevor ich umgezogen bin,
2013,
habe ich meinen ganz,
ganz, ganz, ganz alten
Rechner nochmal eingeschaltet.
Ich hatte noch ein Pentium
2400 von 1997,
also der war da
15 Jahre alt,
16 Jahre alt,
und den hatte ich noch unter dem Tisch stehen damals,
also nicht, den habe ich nicht
verwendet damals, den hatte ich noch
bei mir stehen und ich habe
den eingeschaltet mal, bevor ich
umgezogen bin und den weggeschmissen habe
und der ging noch und
ja,
das war der Rechner, auf dem ich da
das letzte Mal Half-Life gespielt habe damals
mit einer TNT-1 drinnen
und einem 400 MHz Pentium 2
den hatte ich übertaktet
auf 450 MHz mit
Frontside-Bass-Übertakten
damals noch, weil die hatten keine Multiplikatoren,
die man ändern konnte
und ich kam mir wie der ultrakrasseste
Hackerman aller Zeiten vor, Leute,
als ich das gemacht habe.
Ja, und wie gesagt, das ging nach
16 Jahren auch noch, das Ding.
Ist so, dass durch Impulsübertragung
von Elektronen einfach Material
bewegt wird, also ihr könnt euch das einfach vorstellen,
es fließt Strom durch den Leiter,
durch diese winzige Leiterbahn und dadurch wird immer
auch ein, ich sag mal,
Kupferatom wegbewegt.
Das kann dann dazu führen, dass an einer Stelle
sich einfach ein Loch bildet in einem Leiter
oder sich dann eben auch
das Kupfer woanders anreichert,
anlagert, wo es eigentlich gar nicht
hin soll. Die Haupteinflussfaktoren
davon sind elektrischer Strom
und die elektrische Flussdichte.
Das sind die zwei Haupt...
Flussdichte, die die Elektromigration
beeinflussen.
Die Spannung eigentlich nicht als
direkter Faktor, aber als indirekter
Faktor, weil die Spannung
natürlich, wenn man jetzt von einem theoretischen
ohmschen Widerstand ausgeht,
wovon man ausgehen kann, bei einer CPU,
die hauptsächlich aus verschalteten
Kupferleiterbahnen besteht, ist es eben so,
ohmsches Gesetz. Okay, okay, alles gut.
Irgendwie weit
habe ich jetzt ein Problem mit meinem 13.000
900k oder nicht?
Das, wenn der Innenwiderstand
gleich bleibt von der CPU, weil
wir verändern die CPU ja nicht, ist es so,
ihr erhöht die Spannung und damit steigt
auch der Strom und damit steigt auch wieder
die Elektromigration. Also die Spannung an sich
verursacht das eigentlich nicht, aber eben
der höhere Stromfluss, der
dadurch stattfindet.
Die Temperatur ist ein weiterer wichtiger Faktor,
weil dadurch... Ich finde das ja nice, ja.
Also beim Bauer merkst du immer, der hat
richtig Plan von dem, wovon er redet, aber
ich habe keine Ahnung, was
das mit meiner CPU jetzt gerade zu tun hat.
Ob das jetzt meine CPU...
Ob ich jetzt Probleme habe oder nicht?
Begünstigt wird, das heißt Elektromigration ist
einfach einfacher, wenn die Temperatur höher
ist, dann ist es für die Kupfer einfach sich
wegzubewegen. Gleichzeitig ist es
auch so, dass bei einer höheren Temperatur
auch der Innenwiderstand
der CPU sich verändert,
steigt, das ist auch temperaturabhängig,
da sehen wir, wenn wir zum Beispiel eine CPU deutlich
mehr kühlen, dann sinkt auch
gleichzeitig die Leistungsaufnahme. Also so
gesehen die Temperatur ein weiterer Einfluss
hat, der nicht direkt ist, aber eben dann
andere Sachen beeinflusst und dann somit
einen indirekten Einfluss auf die Elektromigration
hat. Kommen wir zurück zu dem Oxidationsthema.
Okay. Dann ist es eben so, ihr müsst euch das vorstellen,
ihr habt... Ich skipte
jetzt mal kurz auf das große Problem.
...von dem eigentlich aus meiner Sicht
viel, viel größeren Problem und
das ist eben... Ach, das war gar nicht so wild.
...der Microcode, also ich sag mal die Software...
Ja, das habe ich mitbekommen, also das weiß
ich, das wusste ich vorher schon, dass es grundsätzlich
zwei Probleme gibt, dass es irgendein
Fertigungsproblem gab und irgendein Firmwareproblem.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gecheckt.
...CPU, die Konfiguration der CPU
fehlerhaft ist, was dazu
führt, dass die 13. und 14. Generation
Intel-CPUs über 65 Watt
dazu neigen, unter
Last und auch im Idle
eine höhere Spannung anliegend
zu haben, weil das ist in der CPU fest
hinterlegt und die CPU sagt dann dem Mainboard,
wie viel Spannung sie haben. Genau, und dafür soll es...
Und dafür soll es angeblich im August
Firmware-Updates geben, wenn das das ist, was ich gesehen habe.
...das auch unter Last, das hat Intel
jetzt reproduziert und auch im Statement gesagt,
zu viel gewesen zu sein,
was dann wieder durch die Elektromigration
eben zu einem deutlich
schnelleren Altern geführt hat, als man das
eigentlich erwartet hatte. Und da möchte ich einmal
ganz kurz zu einem Screenshot
von Igor's Lab switchen, weil der hatte dann
ein sehr, sehr interessantes Statement von Intel.
Da geht es darum, dass an einem Micro-Code-Update
gearbeitet wird, das aber noch nicht fertig ist.
Ist Igor's Lab nicht der,
wo er sich gebeeft hat, immer mal wieder
vor einer Weile?
Da noch irgendwas im Hinterkopf.
...dass die Systeme
nicht beheben. Betroffene
Systeme sollen den Prozessor für die RMA
zurücksenden. Und aus diesem Statement...
Warte, warte, warte...
Ich habe glücklicherweise keine Symptome
bisher, was meine Intel-CPU
angeht.
Schocker, danke für den Sub.
Also bis jetzt ist das Ding super stable.
Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, wann das
zum letzten Mal gecrashed ist, mein Rechner.
Aber ich werde auf jeden Fall das BIOS-Update
machen.
Wobei...
Ist das überhaupt ein BIOS-Update?
Micro-Code-Update geht doch bestimmt
auch über ein Windows-Update, oder?
Meltdown und Gedöns
wurde damals doch auch über
Windows-Sachen verteilt.
Oder musste man damals auch BIOS-Zeug?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Also mit einem BIOS-Update geht es auf jeden Fall.
Was ja streng genommen gar kein BIOS-Update mehr ist.
Jaja, dass das auf der
CPU selbst ist, ist klar.
Aber das muss ja irgendwie dann dahin kommen.
BIOS- oder Betriebssystem-Update. Da wird...
Jetzt werden die doch bestimmt über ein Betriebssystem-Update
verteilen, oder?
Da musst du doch nicht zwangsläufig ein BIOS-Update machen.
Betroffene Systeme sollen
den Prozessor für die RMA zurücksenden.
Und aus diesem Statement kann man
rauslesen, dass Intel sagt...
Selbst wenn wir das jetzt patchen, bedeutet das aber nicht,
dass dann die Instabilität gelöst ist.
Das heißt, die Probleme...
Den Channel kenne ich nicht.
Das ist eher sowas...
Zum...
Zum Schlafen, oder?
So Konsolen-Restaurierungen.
Sowas kann man sich gut angucken, wenn man
patten will.
Die Leute, die ein Problem haben mit einer instabilen CPU...
10% Performance, wollen die mich veräbeln?
10% sind ganz schön viel.
... schon betroffen.
Die sind schon so weit gealtert, dass man die quasi
so nicht mehr einfach retten kann
mit einem einfachen Patch.
Und das deutet für mich ja auch ganz klar darauf hin,
dass logischerweise alle anderen CPUs
auch davon betroffen sein müssen.
Dass die Alterung bei denen dann auch überproportional
schon fortgeschritten ist.
20% ist nicht so, dass die nicht davon betroffen sind.
Bei denen ist nur die Alterung noch nicht
so weit fortgeschritten, dass ihr das jetzt merkt.
Kann aber sein, dass es in einem Monat ist,
oder in einem halben Jahr, oder in einem Jahr,
oder in zwei Jahren.
Deswegen muss ich auf jeden Fall updaten.
Und das ist für mich ein großes Problem.
Wer sich jetzt so ein Video hier anschaut,
oder generell in dieser Bubble unterwegs ist,
sich gut über Hardware informiert,
für den wird es weniger ein Problem sein,
wenn man dann zu Hause einen 14900K hat.
Oder einen 13900K.
Und der läuft aktuell alles fein. Man kann einen Mikrocode-Update machen,
wenn es soweit ist.
Und wenn man Glück hat, wird man niemals
von dem Problem mitbekommen.
Die Sache ist allerdings, dass aus meiner Sicht
die CPUs wahrscheinlich jetzt schon
vorbeschädigt sind,
und weniger lange halten werden,
als es üblicherweise bei Intel-CPUs der Fall ist.
Das ist natürlich davon abhängig,
wie lange hat man die CPU im Einsatz,
wie wurde die im Einsatz benutzt.
Deswegen ist der ganze Fall wahrscheinlich
auch viel bei den professionellen Anwendern,
bei irgendwelchen Spieleentwicklern,
oder sowas aufgefallen.
Was jetzt ein durchschnittlicher Gamer macht,
der halt vielleicht ein paar Stunden am Tag damit zockt,
und ansonsten gar keine Last hat,
oder das Ding gar nicht an ist.
Deswegen fällt es beim durchschnittlichen Gamer
wahrscheinlich viel, viel später auf.
Und der durchschnittliche Gamer ist auch das Problem
an der ganzen Geschichte.
Weil wer sich jetzt nicht in der ganzen Hardware-Szene
so sehr informiert, wie erfährt der von den ganzen Problemen?
Bei dem ist es ja so, wenn der gar nicht davon weiß,
dann macht der vielleicht gar keinen BIOS-Update,
dann altert seine CPU einfach weiter und weiter.
Viele Leute kommen gar nicht auf die Idee.
Die wissen doch nicht mal, dass man einen BIOS-Update überhaupt machen kann.
Und dann vielleicht in ein, zwei Jahren
ist der halt aus der Garantie draußen,
und dann ist die CPU tot.
Wo sie vielleicht normalerweise bei einer normalen Intel-CPU
fünf, sechs, sieben, zehn Jahre gehalten hätte,
hält dann die vielleicht nur die Hälfte.
Und man hat
viel weniger dafür bekommen.
Deswegen ist für mich
die Herangehensweise von Intel, die jetzt kommen wird,
oder vielleicht auch nicht kommt,
das weiß ich eben nicht genau.
Das ist für mich der ausschlaggebende Punkt,
was sich jetzt entwickeln wird.
Ich habe heute mit Intel telefoniert, und da wurde mir versichert,
dass ich das Thema so offen und transparent
wie möglich angehen würde.
Ich habe dann auch gefragt, gibt es da irgendwelche Prozesse,
dass Leute dazu quasi gezwungen werden,
über Partner dann
ein Update auszuführen oder sowas.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber ich frage mich zum Beispiel,
der Großteil der PCs werden ja irgendwelche Fertig-PCs sein.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt irgendwo Fertig-PC gekauft habt,
MediaMarkt oder sowas, ihr habt davon keine Ahnung,
dann flasht sich das Ding ja nicht von alleine.
Wie willst du mitbekommen, dass du deine CPU
eigentlich schützen solltest?
Und das ist die große Frage, die ich mir stelle,
die ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Das müsstest du über Windows-Updates machen, oder?
Falls das geht.
Weil ansonsten ist es so, dass halt wahrscheinlich
Millionen von CPUs viel zu früh sterben
und dann Millionen von...
Aber nach der Garantiezeit, dann freut sich Intel,
klingelt die Kasse wieder.
...Geld ausgegeben haben
für eine CPU, die viel zu früh
den Geist aufgegeben hat, als es eigentlich sein sollte.
Das ist das, was ich sehe,
was passieren könnte.
Und das wäre halt wirklich ein großes Problem.
Weil aktuell, wenn man auch in der Garantie ist,
dann ist es halt nervig, man schickt die ein,
kriegt eine neue, weniger ein Problem.
Problem ist, wenn das halt
nach langer Zeit passiert, lange Zeit dann vielleicht
zwei, drei Jahre, man ist aus dem Garantiezeitraum irgendwie mal raus.
Sollte ich auf gut Glück da hinschreiben,
ich will eine neue CPU?
Ich habe das Ding Dezember 2022 gekauft,
ein paar Monate habe ich noch Zeit.
Vor allem, wo schreibt man hin?
Und dann treten die Fehler auf.
Und dann bekommt man vielleicht keine neue CPU mehr
und man wusste vielleicht gar nicht,
dass man sie hätte schützen sollen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt,
was von Intel Seite passieren wird.
Deshalb sind die Statements, die Intel veröffentlicht hat,
schon mal ein richtiger und guter Weg,
dass man zumindest mal eingeräumt hat,
dass es da ein Problem gibt.
Jetzt ist die Frage, wie wird mit dem ganzen Problem weitergekommen?
Die Fehler waren aber im Jahr 2023 CPUs.
Ne, in dem Statement steht,
dass die ersten
CPUs,
also von dem ursprünglichen Problem,
dass die ersten CPUs
der 13. Generation betroffen waren
und man Mitte 2023
Anpassungen im
Fertigungsprozess gemacht hat,
dass es die Fehler nicht mehr gibt.
Also da ist meine CPU von Dezember 2022
aber mal sowas von mit dabei.
Das Video war interessant für euch.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt noch einen schönen Tag.
Macht's gut bis dahin. Ciao.
So richtig viel schlauer
bin ich jetzt aber auch nicht.
War ein interessantes Video.
So richtig viel schlauer bin ich auch nicht draus geworden.
Also ich mache auf jeden Fall ein BIOS-Update.
Gibt's denn...
Mal kurz checken, ob es für mein Board
schon überhaupt BIOS-Updates
gibt.
Und was für BIOS-Updates
es da gibt. Hallo Leute.
Ja, ja Max, alles klar.
Ich muss meine YouTube-Beschreibung
aktualisieren, sehe ich gerade.
Ich muss den Sibaro fragen.
Discord.
Sibaro-Chan.
Wo ist er denn?
Sibaro.
Matrix, danke für den Sub.
So, okay, das ist natürlich blöd,
wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Domain-Sapps geht auch nicht.
Genau, also mein Mainboard.
Ja.
Lass uns gerade mal gucken,
ob es da schon irgendwelche BIOS-Updates gibt.
REV1?
Was hab ich denn für eins?
REV1, okay, hab ich.
Alles klar.
Warum gibt's da...
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn? Warum gibt's denn da schon wieder
unterschiedliche? Okay, wo...
So ein Support, wird's die BIOS-Updates geben.
BIOS...
Ach, guck mal hier.
Also ich hab noch ein BIOS-Update
gemacht, da hatte ich das Board...
Alter, wie viele BIOS-Updates
gibt's da in der Zwischenzeit schon?
Ich mein nicht, dass man's bräuchte, aber krass.
Also, das da hab ich auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das war ja gut.
Launch, Release.
Das hab ich auch schon.
Und ich hab irgendwann zwischendurch
noch mal geupdatet.
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
welches ich hab. Aber was ist denn da...
Was machen die denn da alles drinne?
Warum gibt's da irgendwie 20 neue BIOS...
Was ist denn da alles im Arsch?
Ja, normalerweise braucht man keine BIOS-Updates
machen.
CPU-Biscuits-Feature.
Äh, ich hab diese hässliche
MSI-Software.
Aber die hab ich hier nicht.
Oder ich kann auch sagen...
Hier ist das, da ist das doch, oder?
Du meinst das da?
Gigabyte-Control-Center?
Nee, nicht MSI. Gigabyte.
Du meinst das da, gell?
Diese Software ist übelst für'n Arsch.
Ich benutze die nie.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Okay, das kommt wieder weg. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das noch überhaupt erzähle.
HW-Info.
Ich hatte hier den Kram, als wir...
Bei Downloads
vielleicht.
Wo wir auch das RGB-Zeug hatten.
Crystal-Disk-Markt. Da kommen wir doch ungefähr in die Richtung
hier.
Ich glaub, das hab ich alles wieder gelöscht.
Was ist das?
Windows-System-Information.
Okay.
Da gibt's
ne BIOS-Version, wirklich?
BIOS-Mode?
Nee, wirklich, oder?
Seht ihr irgendwas in der Richtung?
F3... Echt?
Wo seht ihr das?
Sagt mal Chatgear, ich seh's nicht.
F3G?
Okay, das ist die Release-Version, oder?
Nee.
F3G gibt es nicht.
Was hier hab ich geupdatet?
Okay, Januar.
Das stimmt übrigens auch nicht.
F3G.
Ne Version, die es angeblich gar nicht gibt.
Also, die Version hier hab ich.
Ich hab CPU-Biscuit.
Okay, danach kam noch...
Danach kam noch ein bisschen mehr Zeug,
was aber eigentlich alles nicht
groß relevant ist.
Ja gut, dann werd ich updaten,
sobald's da was zu gibt, ja.
Sobald's ein BIOS-Update gibt.
Gegen diese Intel-Geschichte
werd ich das einspielen.
Das hier ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht dabei.
Was hatten sie hier?
Was ist das?
Ja, das ist irgendeiner Blödsinn.
Dann warte ich, bis es hier ein BIOS-Update gibt
und dann
wird das draufgehauen.
Mal gespannt.
Ist schon kacke, oder?
Wenn irgendwie Grafikkarte,
SSD und CPU
bei einem 5.000 Euro High-End-Rechner
alle Sachen Probleme haben.
Max, gibt es heute
Nudeln mit Lachs?
Ne, heute gibt's Nudeln mit Bolognese.
Leute, ich hab letztens versucht,
Carbonara zu kochen.
Das hat so
semi-gut funktioniert.
Ich hab auf jeden Fall nicht genug Nudelwasser
reingemacht,
sodass ich sehr wenig
Soße hatte.
Der Rest ging aber klar, es hat ganz gut geschmeckt,
aber ein bisschen mehr Nudelwasser muss ich reinmachen.
Die italienische Variante.
Also quasi mit Eier
und Nudelwasser.
Also mit Eigelb,
Nudelwasser
und zwei verschiedenen
Käsesorten.
Das hab ich hingekriegt.
Ich hab aber einfach zu wenig Nudelwasser
reingemacht, deswegen war sehr wenig
Soße dabei.
Zu wenig Soße.
Es hat aber gut geschmeckt.
Wenn man jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr Nudelwasser reinhaut,
also ein bisschen mehr Soße gibt,
dann ist das
excellent.
Ne, das war nicht schlecht, aber
für den ersten Versuch hat es okay geklappt.
Insgesamt war das nur so
semi-gut gemacht.
An sich ist das easy,
aber war mein erster Versuch.
Naja.
Heute könnte ich vielleicht
eine Runde Fahrrad fahren, mal gucken.
Wetter ist ganz okay.
Ja Leute, dann gucken wir doch jetzt mal
das Video von Fireship.
Fireship macht immer coole Videos.
Am I going to jail for webscraping?
Ja, das hätten
manche Seiten sicherlich gerne.
Pass auf, dass ich...
Wobei mich ja gar kein...
Die, die mich umgefahren hat, war keine...
War noch nicht Oma.
Ich hab mich letztens
über eine Oma aufgeregt, die mich geplinkt hat.
Da war ich aber zu Fuß.
Da war ich gar nicht auf dem Fahrrad.
Versteh dich, warum die Leute,
wenn die noch rechts rumfahren wollen,
nicht einfach plinken, dass sie rechts rumfahren lassen.
Äh, dass ich sie rechts rumfahren lasse.
Nicht mal Kreise.
Ganz normal, einfach hier im Ort.
Wollte die rechts in die Straße rein.
Hatte einfach nicht geplinkt.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, hätte die geplinkt,
da hätte ich die ja sogar gelassen.
Aber nachdem die nicht geplinkt hat,
dachte ich mir, ich will weiter geradeaus fahren.
Dann bleibt sie stehen in der Kurve
und guckt mich an und schüttelt den Kopf.
Denke ich mir auch so.
Hätte sie halt geplinkt.
DSGVO.
Eigentlich finde ich es eine sinnvolle Sache.
Ehrlich gesagt, seitdem ich zum letzten Mal
mit meinem Opa, und das schon eine ganze Weile her,
Auto gefahren bin.
Also das war irgendwann, fragt mich nicht,
2005?
Oder so.
Ewig her, 20 Jahre oder so.
Bin ich zum letzten Mal mit meinem Opa
Auto gefahren und
er lebt ja auch nicht mehr.
Aber damals hatte der auch schon ein bisschen
Probleme. Der hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt
und der hat Glück gehabt.
Der hat nicht so viel Bleibendes davongetragen.
Der hat ein bisschen Probleme seinen
einen Fuß schnell zu bewegen.
Was natürlich blöd ist.
Beim Autofahren und mit den Pedalen.
Und da standen wir
an einem Zebrastreifen
und über den Zebrastreifen ist
eine Oma gelaufen vor uns.
Und auf einmal
gibt mein Opa
wie verrückt Gas.
Hast du richtig gehört?
Den Motor vom Auto.
Die Oma, die hat einen Satz gemacht
mit dem Zebrastreifen, hat gedacht
Alter, der überfährt mich jetzt.
Und
beim Opa ist es irgendwie passiert,
dass der, dadurch, dass der eben halt
seinen Fuß nicht mehr so gut koordinieren konnte.
Ich weiß nicht, was er gemacht hat.
Ob er irgendwie
unter den Bremsen
stecken geblieben ist oder
den Fuß irgendwie aufs Gas.
Keine Ahnung, ich kann es euch nicht genau erklären.
Zumindest hat er Gas gegeben.
Glücklicherweise ist das ein Automatikauto
gewesen und er hatte auf Leerlauf
geschaltet.
Also Automatik hat er gehabt
seit dem Zeitpunkt mit dem Schlaganfall.
Und dann hat er halt noch
gelacht danach im Auto so.
Aber mein Opa hat im Auto gelacht,
so weil es ihm peinlich war.
Und die Oma, die über den
Zebrastreifen gegangen ist,
die hat halt einen riesen Schock gekriegt,
Schreck gekriegt, hat einen Satz gemacht
und dann guckt die in das Auto und sieht da halt so
mein Opa drinnen, der da drinnen
sitzt und lacht. Die hat 100 pro gedacht.
Der Typ wollte mich erschrecken
im Auto.
Und
seitdem habe ich mir gedacht, okay
vielleicht sollte nicht mehr
jeder, der Auto fahren darf,
auch wirklich noch Auto fahren.
Weil stell dir mal vor, der hätte nicht
den Leerlauf drinnen gehabt,
sondern das, wie das viele Leute halt machen,
wenn die irgendwo stehen bleiben, halt einfach
auf die Bremse gedrehten.
Der hätte die Oma umgefahren.
Und
ja, also seitdem
denke ich mir halt schon die ganze Zeit,
nur weil jemand Auto fahren darf,
heißt das nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig, dass der Auto fahren sollte.
Deswegen finde ich
diesen Check,
sofern er nicht zu übertrieben ist, gar nicht so
verkehrt.
Ne, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das der Zweck
davon gewesen ist.
Sehr andere Probleme.
Das ist echt eine Scheißkrankheit.
Das wünscht man keinem.
Eins dieser beschissenen Sachen,
die es gibt, gucken wir uns mal
das Firehsweep-Video an.
Ich mach jetzt Musik aus.
Oh ne, kommt jetzt ein Binary- played-
Ja, ich habe auch schon
die DHL-AP web-scraped.
... und die UPS-API.
Wobei Webgescraped das falsche Wort ist.
UPS habe ich Webgescraped und DHL habe ich mit irgendeinem Fake-API-Key,
der aus irgendwelchen Gründen funktioniert.
Das gibt es sogar noch.
Das gibt es sogar irgendwie sogar auf GitHub noch, vor fünf Jahren.
Ich habe mal versucht, so einen Versand-Tracker zu bauen,
der mehrere Versandservices unterstützt.
Da konnte Hermes...
DHL und EPD und Amazon, genau, konnte er ja auch.
Und das habe ich...
Das muss ich mal kurz mal so gucken, bin ich mir gar nicht mehr...
Warum ist da Console-App 1 drin? Was macht das da?
Geil.
Max, hast du sehr gut committet.
Das musste unbedingt committet werden, das Ding hier.
Console-App 1.
So, und da hatte ich irgendwo Backgrounds...
Genau, DHL, hier DHL-Tracker, DPD-Tracker, Hermes-Tracker, UPS-Tracker.
So, und der UPS-Tracker, der ging an den UPS-API-Endpoint...
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder, genau.
Ich habe...
Ha, jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Ich habe die UPS-Webseite mitgeschnitten, was die für Traffic macht,
und habe festgestellt, die haben einen API-Key,
den die aber an jeden Client ausliefern.
Also quasi ein öffentlich bekannter API-Key.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das das ist, was UPS wirklich machen wollte.
So, und dann musste man an den Endpunkt gehen von UPS.
Man musste sagen, dass man Firefox ist, sonst hat es, glaube ich, nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Ja, und dann musste man das exakt in diesem Format schicken, sonst ging es nicht.
Also das ist nicht wirklich klassisches Web-Scraping, wie das Fireship nennt,
aber es ist auch kein legit API-User.
Das ist ein legit API-Key-Request, ja.
Ja, und bei Hermos braucht man, glaube ich, brauchte man, glaube ich, gar kein API-Key.
Ja, Hermos habe ich auch aus dem JSON der Webseite irgendwie extrahiert.
Was ist denn das, was ich da mache?
Das ist nicht richtig Web-Scraping, das ist aber auch nicht richtig ganz offiziell über die API.
Das ist quasi eine private API abgegriffen.
Das ist...
Das ist auch nicht mal...
Das ist eher, das ist API-Access, aber auf einen Endpunkt, wo man eigentlich gar nicht gehen soll.
By the way, mir fällt mal gerade auf, dass das sogar relativ ordentlich programmiert ist.
Das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht erwartet.
Und wie funktioniert der DPD-Tracker?
Ja, das ist so Halb-Web-Scraping hier.
Try five times...
So, und ich bilde mir ein bei DHL.
Ja, bei DHL musste ich einen API-Key verwenden, genau.
Aber das ist auch irgendein API-Key, der, ich weiß nicht, wo ich den herhabe, eventuell auch aus der Webseite extrahiert oder so.
Aber hauptsache mal committed in shit.
So, gucken wir das Video weiter.
There's only two types of people in this world.
The conformist API-Consumer and the renegade Web-Scraper.
It's always been a bit of a grey area to write code that automatically extracts valuable data from websites.
But will you go to jail if you do it?
You are stealing right to jail.
I refuse to go back to jail, but I'm literally...
I'm literally shaking right now because the US District Court in Delaware just ruled that Booking.com violated the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act by scraping the Ryanair website.
Booking tried to countersue for defamation because Ryanair hurt the corporation's feelings by calling them an OTA pirate or online travel agency pirate.
Not surprisingly, the court rejected that claim, but this is not the first time that Web-Scrapers have battled in court.
In today's video, we'll look at the legal and ethical concerns in this case and find out if my Web-Scraping tutorials will land you in jail.
In this weird cybernetic post-human world, data has become more valuable than gold.
Google and Meta are both trillion-dollar companies built almost exclusively by collecting data from users to be exploited by advertisers.
For the last 30 years, humans have voluntarily and involuntarily filled the world wide web with exabytes of data about our crappy lives.
And much of this data is freely available through the lens of a web browser.
But the problem is that the right-wing media is not the only one.
Raw data is trapped inside a rock of HTML code, rendering it useless for data analysis.
The data becomes valuable, though, when it's mined into a clean universal format like JSON or CSV that can be fed into machine learning tools like XGBoost or sold to data brokers on the black market.
And that's where Web-Scraping comes in.
I've made tutorials about how to do it at an industrial scale using tools like Puppeteer, which can render the content on a website programmatically, click on buttons, fill out forms, and order, which can render the content on a website programmatically.
Puppeteer is sehr nice.
Das habe ich auch schon verwendet.
Was ist denn eigentlich aktuell so das Angesagte?
Du hast ja, die Oldschool-Leute benutzen Selenium, dann gibt's noch Puppeteer, dann gibt's noch Playwright.
Ich glaube, die coolen Leute heute verwenden Playwright, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was der Unterschied zwischen Playwright und Puppeteer ist.
Aber Playwright habe ich noch nicht verwendet, Puppeteer schon.
On a website programmatically, click on buttons, fill out forms, and ultimately extract valuable data.
Despite content being freely available, like Amazon product listings, for example,
many website owners don't like Puppeteer.
They like to be scraped and forbid this behavior in their terms of service.
Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe euch das schon mal erzählt, dass mich einer der Domain-Registrare, wo ich Domains habe,
dass die mich gebannt haben.
Playwright ist cool.
Ja, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Puppeteer und Playwright?
Die haben mich gebannt, und zwar, damals hatten die noch keine DNS-API.
Also über eine DNS-API für Let's Encrypt.
Also im Prinzip, dass du Text-Records anlegen kannst,
im DNS, sodass du Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate ausstellen kannst.
So, aber was du mit Certboard machen kannst, du kannst ja mit Certboard Custom-Scripts ausführen.
Also bin ich kurzerhand hin und habe mit Puppeteer eine Automatisierung gebaut,
für denen ihre Webseite, wo ich TXT-Records anlegen konnte.
Im Prinzip halt, indem ich getan habe, dass ich ein Webbrowser bin,
und habe die Sachen dort wie von Hand halt automatisiert zusammengeklickt,
damit ich mir Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate ausstellen kann, automatisiert.
Und irgendwie hatte ich einen Bug drin, und das Ding hat sich versucht, zehnmal anzumelden.
Und dann ist denen ihre Anti-Spam-Security-Sache angesprungen und hat meine IP geblacklisted.
Weil, ich war halt auch blöd, dass ich das von mir daheim ausgemacht habe, ja.
Anstatt über irgendeinen Server drüber gehoppt oder so.
Da haben die mich blacklisted, weil die gedacht haben,
ey, der Typ, der macht komisches.
Der macht komisches Zeug, ja.
Dann habe ich da hingeschrieben.
Dann habe ich da hingeschrieben und habe gesagt, sorry, Leute, ich habe mich da verscriptet.
Könnt ihr mich wieder freischalten?
Es kommt auch nicht mehr vor.
Kappa.
Und da haben die gesagt, ja, wir finden das eigentlich nicht so geil, wenn unsere Webseite gescraped wird.
Aber wir haben dich wieder freigeschaltet.
So.
Tag später habe ich mir das Skript genommen, habe das angepasst, habe vergessen, den Part rauszuschreiben, äh, rauszulöschen, auszukommentieren, habe es ausgeführt, wieder blacklisted.
Und dann musste ich die nochmal anschreiben.
Sorry, Leute, ich habe mich nur vertan.
Ich habe mich nur vertan.
Ich wollte eigentlich Amazon-Web scrapen.
Und hatte noch Teile von eurer Webseite.
Das ist in eurem Skript drin.
Und jetzt habe ich mich wieder blacklisted.
Könnt ihr mich nochmal freischalten?
Haben sie auch gemacht.
Sie haben mich nochmal freigeschaltet.
Seitdem habe ich es sicherheitshalber nicht mehr ausgeführt.
Und wenn ich das nochmal machen würde, dann nicht mehr von daheim aus.
Und außerdem, mittlerweile haben die sogar eine normale DNS-API.
Also, vollkommen irrelevant.
Ja, aber die meisten Webseiten, da hat er schon recht.
Mögen das nicht so.
... und robots.txt-File.
But this file is like the no smoking signs on an airplane.
It doesn't actually stop anything from happening.
And you can easily enjoy a cigarette on a plane.
Just like the good old days.
However, the flight attendant might come over to you
and tell you to stop doing that
and ban you from the airline.
Website owners can do the same thing
by banning your IP address if they suspect you're a scraper.
Wo wir es gerade vom Thema hatten.
Now, to bypass this ban,
a smoker can change his identity,
reboard the plane,
and take a few more drags.
Webscrapers can do the same thing.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das geht nicht.
Ich habe ja nicht nur bei einem Anbieter Domains.
Ich habe, glaube ich, bei...
Also, bei mindestens vier, die mir jetzt einfallen, Domains.
Nee, fünf. Fünf.
Ich habe ja immer noch eine Domain bei Nitrado, Alter.
Fragt mich bitte nicht, warum ich bei Nitrado...
Eine! Eine Domain habe ich bei Nitrado, Mann.
...
Ich habe Sachen bei
Porkbun,
Namecheap, Namesilo,
Nitrado,
Cloudflare.
Nee, kein CS-Server.
Bei GoDaddy habe ich
nichts, soweit ich mich erinnern kann.
Brauchst du nicht.
Der DNS,
auf den der eingestellt ist
für die Domain,
braucht das.
Was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst die Domain,
die DNS-Server umstellen,
auf beispielsweise Cloudflare.
Das funktioniert.
Jaja, das geht.
Dann benutzt du aber nicht mehr die DNS-Server
vom Domain-Registrar,
sondern halt von Cloudflare.
Das funktioniert, dass du sagen kannst, ey,
für diese Domain zum Auflösen zuständig
ist jetzt nicht mehr der
Registrar-DNS, sondern der Cloudflare-DNS.
Ja, das geht. Das kann man machen.
Hatte ich nicht.
Ich wollte das auch gar nicht umziehen
auf Cloudflare.
Da hat nahezu jeder
Domain-Anbieter eine API für Let's Encrypt.
Also im Prinzip brauchst du ja bloß eine
API, wo du TXT-Records anlegen kannst.
Welche Anbieter findest du
am besten? Ganz ehrlich, Cloudflare
finde ich am angenehmsten.
Das einzige Problem ist,
geht das?
Das kann überhaupt,
das kann doch gar nicht funktionieren.
Wenn du Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge
machst,
dann guckt der nach,
auf welchen DNS
der geht zu dem DNS, der
für diese Domain hinterlegt ist.
Und wenn ich sage, Let's Encrypt,
ich will ein Zertifikat für
wublos.tv,
dann muss der DNS,
der für wublos.tv zuständig
ist, einen TXT-Record haben, der dazu passt.
Wenn ich eine Domain
habe, was weiß ich, bei Cloudflare
MaxFPS.tv,
dann bringt mir das
in dem Fall doch nichts.
Wie soll das gehen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Wie soll sich das nennen?
Achso!
Du meinst, du legst einmalig
auf dem DNS,
der für wublos.tv
zuständig ist,
einen CNAME an,
der dann
auf was zeigt? Auf den anderen,
auf die andere Domain.
Und dann geht der da hin und guckt nach,
wo dieser DNS-Server einen TXT-Record
legt.
Ja, das...
Das heißt, ich könnte... Ja, such mal raus!
Das wäre ganz praktisch.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir auch
für maxfps.de, was noch
bei Nitrado liegt, was passiert eigentlich da,
wenn man da hingeht aktuell?
Nix? Okay, gut, so sollte es auch sein.
Dann könnte ich
umstellen, könnte ich ein CNAME machen
auf, keine Ahnung, wublos.tv
und dann dort ins... Okay, das ist ganz gut
zu wissen, ja.
Anbieter, also ich mag Cloudflare tatsächlich am besten,
weil die sich super bedienen lassen.
Letztendlich, also sowohl
Webinterface als auch API-Technik,
ansonsten ist es eigentlich fast egal, welchen du nimmst.
Die haben mittlerweile alle ähnliche Möglichkeiten.
Ja, ich bin
immer noch skeptisch, dass das wirklich
funktioniert.
Aber wie bringst du das
beispielsweise deinem Reverse-Proxy
oder deinem Certbot bei,
dass der... Na gut,
du sagst ihm einfach, bei diesem DNS
Einträge hinterlegen und gut ist.
Das müsste ich tatsächlich mal ausprobieren,
das ist nicht schlecht.
Aber wie funktioniert das?
Wie soll das denn dann funktionieren?
Also,
nehmen wir mal das Beispiel.
Nehmen wir mal hier ein Beispiel, okay?
Also, sagen wir mal, ich habe hier maxfps.de
Das liegt bei Nitrado und Nitrado
kann keine, hier, ohne
DNS-API, ja.
Dann habe ich,
sagen wir mal, wublos.tv
Und
die haben nur DNS-API.
So, dann würde ich
quasi hier einen CNAME
hinterlegen auf
wublos.tv
oder wie?
Also ein CNAME ist ja quasi
eine Art Alias, oder?
Das ist immer so ein bisschen DNS,
DNS-Stelz.
So, also was
was hinterlege ich hier jetzt
bei maxfps.de?
Weil letztendlich hier,
muss ja der Third-Bot sein Zeug machen.
So, hier würde der Third-Bot,
also der DNS ist dann, keine Ahnung, hier
5, 7
Punkt irgendwas, aber das wäre der DNS.
So, und da müsste das Third-Bot über
die API anlegen
maxfps.de
txt-record
bzw. txt nicht,
einfach nur einen txt-record anlegen
mit der Challenge
drinne. Und das
funzt wirklich!
Das erscheint mir irgendwie
merkwürdig.
Was für einen CNAME muss ich hier anlegen?
Was muss da rein?
Ja, irgendwie sowas, ja.
Ich mein, dass das hier
prinzipiell geht, ist klar.
Ich mein, ich kann in jedem DNS beliebig was
eintragen. Ob der DNS dafür zuständig ist, ist
was anderes. Normalerweise wird er dann deswegen nicht
gefragt. Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Also da bin ich, da bin ich irgendwie
aber es ist nice. Also wenn das geht,
wäre sehr praktisch.
Dann könnte man quasi alle seine
Challenges gegen den gleichen
Server machen, gerade wenn die das nicht unterstützen.
Doch, das geht auch.
Das geht auch. Das geht. Das geht.
Das geht. Du kannst
umstellen bei deinem Registrar, welcher
Domain Server, welcher DNS Server dafür zuständig ist.
Dann geht das.
Das funktioniert, ja.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das geht, aber
keine Ahnung. Ne, das Ding ist ja,
der hier hat ja keine
DNS-API.
Hier muss es irgendeinen statischen
Rekord geben, der dann automatisch da drauf
zeigt, so. So.
Und Certbot müsste dann
quasi hierfür gucken,
welcher DNS ist dafür zuständig,
hier einen TXT-Rekord hinterlegen.
Und dann kriege ich ein
Zertifikat für wublos.tv.
Das ist ja alles interessant,
ja. Das... Ich meine,
es ist wahrscheinlich für die meisten Sachen komplett
overkill, weil die meisten Anbieter
eine DNS-API haben, beziehungsweise man es einfach
auf Cloudflow umstellen könnte.
Aber insgesamt finde ich das ganz spannend,
dass das anscheinend geht, ja.
Wie muss man Cloud... gar nicht.
Cloudflare
hat ein ziemlich großzügiges Free-Tier.
Du musst bei Cloudflare noch nicht mal deine
Kreditkarte hinterlegen, das heißt, die können gar
nichts abrechnen, selbst wenn sie wollen.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir das Video angucken
von FireShip, das gucken wir uns jetzt auch an. Fertig.
Das ist aber schon shady teilweise, ganz ehrlich.
Da habe ich mich auch mal ein bisschen mit beschäftigt.
Diese Geschichte hier, da brauchst du ja einen Anbieter,
der das macht, ja.
Und so die Anbieter,
die dir quasi
50.000 Exit-IPs
bereitstellen,
die sind sehr shady
oftmals, ja.
Man kann sich natürlich auch einfach 4Ms mieten,
bei Amazon oder bei Hetzner.
Wenn es einem
Labatoir, dann hast du ja auch
nur eine begrenzte Anzahl an Exit-Nodes.
Also du kannst
natürlich dir drei, vier
Kisten mieten
und dann darüber das Ganze
balancen.
Aber wenn du viel Traffic machst, reicht das nicht.
Also die richtig harten
Webscraper brauchen dann irgendeinen Service, der dir 20
30.000 IPs zur Verfügung stellt,
über die du deine Sachen, und die sind so oftmals
sehr shady, diese Anbieter.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht nur die Website abschneiden,
sondern auch Reihen-Air-Tickets verkaufen,
ohne ihre Befragung.
Nicht nur war ihre Webscraper vorhanden,
sondern auch der Wunsch, sich zu befreien.
Nun, wenn du ein Scraper bist,
dann willst du mit deinem Arbeiter reden,
über den Computer-Fraud- und Verbrechen-Akt,
oder CFAA,
der bis 1986 eröffnet wurde.
2015 gab es eine Firma namens 3Taps,
die Daten aus Craigslist ausgeschnitten hat
für eine Website namens Padmapper.
Craig war nicht so glücklich darüber
und blockierte ihre IP-Adressen und schickte eine
E-Mail, aber die Firma
schlug weiter, bis sie verurteilt wurde.
Das Gericht beschloss Craigslist,
und setzte den Voraus, dass Online-Hosts
den CFAA nutzen können, um öffentliche Daten zu schützen.
Letztendlich verabschiedeten sich 3Taps
und schlugen Craig nicht wieder,
und zahlen 1 Millionen Dollar.
Die Grundlage ist, dass, wenn eine Firma
dir sagt, du musst stoppen, musst du stoppen,
oder du wirst verurteilt werden.
Aber 2019 gab es noch einen High-Profile-Fall,
High-Q-Labs vs. LinkedIn.
Sie schlugen Daten aus LinkedIn, um zu präsentieren,
wann ein Mitarbeiter ihren Job verlassen würde.
Dieses Mal regierte das Gericht in Bezug auf High-Q,
um LinkedIn's öffentliche Daten anzunehmen.
Und diese Entscheidung wurde
letztendlich durch den Supreme Court verabschiedet.
Und nur ein paar Wochen vor,
bekamen Scrapers noch einen großen Wettbewerb.
Wenn man ein AI-Tool wie GitHub Copilot baut,
und ein paar Open-Source-Code schlägt,
um es zu trainieren, sollte man gut gehen.
Dieses Gesetz, das sagt, Copilot verabschiedet
die Lizenzen und verweigert die Rechte
von möglichen Millionen Software-Developern,
wurde von einem Gericht verabschiedet,
was bedeutet, dass es nicht wiedergefiltert werden kann.
Und das bringt uns zurück zu unserer originalen Frage,
ob ich in den Gefängnis gehen werde, um ein Website zu scrapen.
Nun, ich bin kein Gericht, aber wenn man öffentlich
verfügbare Daten verfügt und niemanden verfügbar macht,
sind die Chancen, in den Gefängnis zu gehen,
extrem niedrig. Und das Einzige, worüber man sich interessiert,
ist, wenn eine Megacorporation dich finanziell
für den Rest deines Lebens verurteilt.
Das war's mit dem Code-Report. Danke fürs Zuschauen
und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video.
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
es echt gut zu wissen ja ich habe mir das mal ob die meisten die mario playlist heißt es ist
einfach youtube youtube happy and chill soft nintendo music kannst du suchen ja aber die
coolen leute verwenden xos hast du bald geburtstag ja dauert nicht mehr so lange ich sage euch nicht
wann genau aber ein paar tage ist es noch da bin ich 40 da muss schon wieder ein video machen ich
habe sogar letzten auf der arbeit noch jemand gefragt max wolltest du nicht mich hat letztens
letztens freitag hat mich einer gefragt von den leuten auf der arbeit magst hast du nicht gesagt
du arbeitest montag oder du du du arbeitest halten nicht teils am montag du bist montags nicht da
dass du dich montags um youtube kümmern kannst das hat ja richtig dass so sieht das aus aber
die aber ich habe gesehen was gar keine youtube videos gemacht in letzter zeit es wird echt es
wird echt verzeiht wenn du auf der arbeit schon angesprochen wir es dass du kein youtube
videos war was da weißt du bescheid out gecallt ja lul hd ich meine das naheliegendste wäre ich
mache mal ein update video wie das jetzt so ist nach über einem jahr jobwechsel wollte ich machen
schon lange her eigentlich wollte ich das im april machen als es genau ein jahr her ist und
ich brauche auch ein neues gehalts updates video das sind zwei themen die sind so
wie sagt man so schön low hanging fruits wo ich weiß dass das auch views gibt die leute vor allem
interessiert gerade die gehalts updates videos die sind immer super beliebt interessiert die
leute immer was es an kohle gibt ich muss aber da halt auch jedes mal dabei sagen frankfurter
finanzbranche und das und das nicht dass die vielleicht muss ich das auch noch ein bisschen
deutlicher sagen nicht dass man auf die idee kommt wenn man jetzt irgendwo im dresdner hinterland ist
bei einem zwei mann betrieb da sind die umstände einfach ganz anders gehaltserhöhung bekommen ja
aber nicht weil ich irgendwie großartig gesagt hätte ich will eine es gibt es gab eine einmal
zahlung für die inflation und es gab dieses jahr ich glaube irgendwie knapp das ist 33,5 prozent
oder irgendwie sowas gab es mehr und dann habe ich noch irgendwie
einfach 200 euro mehr bekommen im monat weil ich in so einer rufbereitschaft liste drin stehe in der
ich aber schon die ganze zeit drin stehe da weiß ich auch nicht warum aber ich beschwere mich nicht
ich beschwere mich nicht übrigens wenn ich hier von irgendwelchen betrieben geredet da ist das
immer bevor ich steuern drauf bezahlt haben also am ende bleibt von 200 euro immer nur 100 euro
übrig da ein bisschen mehr 120 euro übrig fragt mich ab da ich so viel steuern bezahlen muss aber
okay was willst du machen nach madeira ziehen was sind die ganzen influencer wobei ist madeira
überhaupt noch angesagt zwischenzeitlich sind manche nach dubai aber das ist glaube ich auch
nicht mehr so das war der main character nicht in dubai was macht er was macht er eigentlich
moment da muss ich jetzt einfach mal kurz gucken wenn ich gerade dabei bin was macht er eigentlich
sein channel heißt doch gar nicht mehr so ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie der channel heißt
nicht mal abo red der hat doch jetzt eine andere
das macht er eigentlich läuft der in sie modus noch ist da noch in dubai eigentlich das ist
ein ding mich interessiert sich wirklich aber bei ihm irgendwie interessiert mich dann doch
ab und zu was da so los ist der markt crypto scams wirklich ein vorstellen könnte ich mir
der wollte der wollte
mit irgendeinem dubai video die leute gegen so eine komische trading trading abo locken und sowas
bei abo red frage ich mich immer ist das alles pure absicht oder steigt er nicht so genau durch
wenn er für sowas werbung macht weil die leute können ja auch viel erzählen wenn der tag lang
ist ich erwähne keine leute mehr namentlich im chat die ich nicht kenne weil ich wurde einmal
richtig hart gebetet könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern als mal
irgendwie das ist das war ganz am das war ganz am anfang als ich angefangen habe zu streamen da kam
ja auch mal irgendjemand rein kannst du kannst du uns grüßen und da habe ich gesagt ja hier ich
grüße sowieso sowieso hat sich herausgestellt am ende das war irgend so einen shop mit mit
schmuckstücken die versucht haben die leute zu scammen und dann hatten die den clip auf ihrer
webseite was ist irgendwie mehr für mehr credit credit billet ich kann das wort nicht aussprechen
mehr für mehr glaubwürdigkeit sorgen soll
dass die erwähnt werden von von irgendwelchen leuten auf twitch und da habe ich keinen bock
mehr darauf dass wenig keine leute mehr namentlich vor allem nicht wenn es leute sind ich noch nie
gehört habe du wirst halt für jeden du wirst versucht mittlerweile mit jedem mist für den
sap du wirst dann echt versucht mittlerweile für jeden mist mit jedem mist zu scammen was
blöd für die leute die es ernst meinen ja ich will ja gar nichts unterstellen ich kann ja
durchaus sein dass das ernst gemeint ist ja und legit und ohne scam und alles
aber leider weiß man das ja nicht kann man sagen ist dass das ist okay das ist wie die leute nicht
on-premise sagen sondern on-prem weil das cooler ist die schere zwischen arm und reich können also
ist die schere zwischen arm und reich in dubai quasi überall so wie am frankfurter hauptbahnhof
nur nicht nur am hauptbahnhof sondern überall schlimmer ich weiß nicht ob ob es also vielleicht
von beträgen her aber ganz ehrlich ich ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es so viel schlimmer
sein kann wie am frankfurter hauptbahnhof weil du hast am frankfurter hauptbahnhof die leute die in
der ecke liegen kurz vorm verrecken sind plus irgendwelche millionenschwere manager dudes die
vorbeilaufen also ich gehe davon aus dass es dort ähnlich ist aber halt einfach überall oder anders
das habe ich auch schon
also ich habe am frankfurter hauptbahnhof schon echt richtig krasses weird champ zeug ich kann
mich noch daran erinnern als wir von der berufsschule mal zurückgelaufen sind also
paar leute zusammen von der berufsschule da ist uns am frankfurter hauptbahnhof so
einen typ in windeln entgegen gekommen fragt nicht warum dann in windeln ich habe keine ahnung
so ein typ in windeln zu rechts wenn du rum vielleicht für die leute die am frankfurter
hauptbahnhof schon mal gewesen sind wenn ihr vom hauptbahnhof rechts rum geht gegen den seiten
richtung seiteneingang von mcdonald's da stehen ja immer die fertigen leute ja da sind verlangen
gelaufen ist quasi google maps also wenn ihr hier genau wie dreht man eigentlich die karte
am desktop wisst ihr das
am handy weiß ich da wie dreht man die karte am desktop das ist jemand mit alt oder so vielleicht
kontroll rechte maustaste kontrollen am desktop geht ab deshalb geht das nicht ok google maps
turn app desktop shift beide maustasten weil da war alles durch shift control turn app google
desktop browser
ok how to rotate maps step on step
wie die antwort ist
gehe auf sein handy
geht nicht
zumindest ist es auch vollkommen egal ich will das also hier neben geht es hier ist der mcdonalds irgendwo an der seite
das ist der haupteingang wenn ich wenn ihr hier rum geht hier sind immer sehr sehr viele asis am start so
ich glaube mittlerweile ist sogar das hier gar nicht mehr möglich darum zu gehen weil sie irgendwie was bauen an der unterführung und da hier
egal zumindest
stimmt google google earth ja
Klickt man auf die ebenen und dann 3d klo bus ich muss auf google earth wahrscheinlich
Globus und sich jetzt
Globus ansicht
Das ist nicht so einfach wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe wir gehen jetzt auf google earth
sind wir in hemsbach in mönchfries genau
frankfurter
haupt
bahnhof
ja
jetzt
das war so schön aha hier geht es okay hier geht es hier geht es
ich das ist das ist schon nice gemacht muss man echt mal sagen oder so schon cool
so weil man hier auch irgendwie street street view und kann
genau hier so an dieser ecke
was wie hier sind keine street view daten verfügbar man hat es doch gerade gesehen
da wurde doch eben explizit street view angezeigt oder
die habe ich gebetet
die habe ich
alle die habe ich super krass gebetet hier waren doch eben zwei street view dinger
Ich habe doch eben diese blauen punkte gesehen es ist auch vollkommen egal
zumindest sind wir hier vorbei gelaufen
da stand halt hier irgendwo ist auf der höhe stand also ein typ mit mit mit mit windeln an
und dann alle leute auf der straße angequatscht
und
uns uns dann auch ja alle leute angequatscht
aber mit was wir hatten wir hatten drei mädels in der berufsschulklasse ja mehr gab es bei uns fachinformatiker klasse nicht
und wir sind an dem vorbei gelassene war dabei wir sind wir sind wir sind ein typ mit windeln vorbei gelaufen
bei euch gab es nur ja
und dann kommt er so von der seite und meint sie wie hart
hallo schöne frau
die wasser ist sinngemäß so was in der richtung hat er von sich gegeben
oder irgendwie so du bist auch eine schöne frau oder irgendwie sowas
okay wir
denn da werde ich an der ihrer stelle jetzt echt
wäre mir das nicht ganz nicht ganz wohl gewesen wenn mich irgend so ein random typ von der seite in der windel am hauptbahnhof
anspricht dass ich auch eine schöne frau bin
Also gerade also diese ecke hier leute
hier geht es hier geht es zum mcdonalds rein irgendwo dann
Ich glaube hier so an der seite nicht ganz sicher und
Diese ecke das ist immer abartig eklig warum hat er eben ja ihr habt doch auch gesehen oder dass der mir hier
Eindeutig hatte der mir eben streetview sachen angezeigt okay jetzt nicht mehr
egal
also das sieht so
das sieht schon so runtergekommen aus am hauptbahnhof irgendwie
allein schon beim gucken
sieht es
guck mal da stehen irgendwelche komischen gestalten im schatten rumme
allein schon beim angucken sieht das sich das aus die ecke
Wobei so die richtigen richtigen
assi gambler die sind ja eigentlich hier in der nebenstraße und lasst mich mal gucken ob es davon bilder gibt
Also hier gammeln auch ganz gerne leute
An diesen eingängen kann man die vielleicht bisschen schneller google please geht es ein bisschen geht es ein bisschen schneller
an diesen eingängen an diesen eingängen zum
Zum hauptbahnhof hier unten und so da hängen sie auch immer ab hier war früher eine sparkasse
Und da hängen die ganzen drogenabhängigen davor in der hoffnung feld irgendwie geld runter oder so hier ist hier ist der eingang zur unterführung
und hier vorne das war auch
Hier vorne ist ein geldautomaten der in der wirklich
uneinsehbarsten
ähm, zwielichtigsten so Ecke
so, ist ein Geldautomat.
Da kann man nicht mal dahinter gucken.
Ja, hier ist ein Geldautomat dahinter.
By the way. So, dass man schön ausgeraubt werden kann,
dass keiner sieht. Und...
Kann man da...
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht in das
Geschäft rein. Ja. Und da hatten
wir mal, während wir Geld geholt haben,
während wir Geld hier geholt haben,
haben
drei Schwarze neben uns irgendwelches Zeug
gedealt. Zwei Meter weiter hier.
Da war es
uns auch etwas, sagen wir mal,
äh, unangenehm
Geld holen zu müssen, direkt daneben.
Hier so. Ja.
Der Geldautomat ist hier um die Ecke.
Hier, rechts rum.
Ja, da hast du schon die
Jute hier irgendwo. Da ist er! Guck hier!
Ja. Hier ist übrigens,
das ist mittlerweile, äh, ist es
wieder auf? Eigentlich immer noch
zu. Da möchte ich mein Geld
holen. Zumindest,
anscheinend gibt es da Fußgänger-Streetview. Ist mir auch
neu. Ist, hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Zumindest, wir gucken uns jetzt mal was
an. Frankfurt.
Niederstraße.
Haben wir da Streetview?
So, hier diese, diese
Gammelseitenstraßen hier.
Diese Gammelseitenstraßen.
Ja.
Da hängen sie, da hängen sie immer
ab, man. Und je nachdem,
die werden, die werden, umso weiter, umso näher
du Richtung Hauptbahnhof kommst.
Ich würde gerne ein bisschen schneller mich fortbewegen,
Google, wenn das möglich ist.
Streetview von daher, ja klar.
Äh,
natürlich gleich Polizei am Start,
was sonst? Und umso mehr
du da hingehst,
so Niederstraße, Taunusstraße,
also hier geht's noch,
hier geht's noch. Ich such das gerade.
Kann man das immer nicht, ja, hier so ein bisschen.
Also,
sagen wir mal, so Niederstraße ist ganz, ganz
abartig hier oftmals, so an den Einmündungen.
Hier so in der Ecke.
Hier hast du die ganzen,
hier hast du die ganzen Spezialisten.
Das muss ein Bild sein, was relativ
früh entstanden ist, glaube ich.
Ja.
Hier, hier ist auch so ein Ding, ja.
Guckt doch mal auf die Straße hier.
Hier hast du nur vom
Feinsten in Frankfurt an der Ecke gerade.
Ja.
Nur vom Feinsten.
Das muss irgendwie während Corona-Zeit
gewesen sein.
Das ist so eine typische Ecke hier unten in Frankfurt,
Alter. So, und hier auch.
Ey, guckt's euch an, Mann.
Hier hast du schon, hast du schon die ersten
am Start. Hat sie, die hat sich irgendwas,
gerade gespritzt und ist irgendwie in einer
anderen Welt. Da auch hier.
Hier haben wir
eine Straße gefunden, ne.
Da sind sie hier. Die ganzen Spezialisten,
Alter.
Moselstraße, ja.
Ja.
Da wird, da wird die nächste Mahlzeit
zubereitet gerade.
Ich hatte auch schon hier jemanden zwischen
den Autos sitzen, der hat zwischen die Autos gekackt.
Der saß dann hier dazwischen,
Hose runter, hat hier zwischen die Autos geschissen.
Übrigens,
wenn ihr hier langlauft, Leute, ich empfehle euch
nicht unbedingt hier lang zu, lang zu laufen,
wenn ihr, wenn ihr es vermeiden könnt.
Die, gerade
diese Ecke, da stinkt's auch übertrieben
in dieser Straße. Und was witzig war,
während, während EM,
absolut
richtig, Premium Hotel,
Mosel Hotel, Premium, Leute.
Premium Hotel.
Ähm, während der EM
war das
tatsächlich zum ersten
Mal halbwegs sauber.
Die haben alle Leute verscheucht und haben
sauber gemacht morgens. Da sind auch morgens
immer irgendwelche Putzwagen
durchgefahren in, in einer Menge, die
ich bisher noch nicht gesehen habe in Frankfurt.
Aber
mittlerweile ist es wieder, ist es wieder
exakt, das, das gleiche.
So, jetzt zeige ich euch nochmal kurz die Copy-Paste.
Also hier hast du die ganzen,
die ganzen Spezialisten, Alter, hast du
hier in Frankfurt. Die Ecke,
das ist wirklich ohne Scheiß, diese Ecke.
Das ist einfach
Frankfurt, Bahnhofsviertel pur.
Ja. Sieht runtergekommen
as fuck aus. Irgendwelche Leute
gerade noch am Spritzen auf der Straße.
Ja. Diese Ecke.
Das ist, das ist, das, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, Frankfurt ist nicht schlimm.
Das Bahnhofsviertel
ist scheiße. Darum umgeht das.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
Copy, Copy-Paste, die
Copy-Paste-Straße.
Wollen wir mal gucken. Mosel
Hotel Frankfurt. Was haben die so
für Bewertungen?
Oh, ja, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Hat, hat Google da keine
Bewertung selbst? Achso, das ist DuckDuckGo.
Ah, null.
Achtung!
Das ist die schlechteste Bewertung.
Sieht man dazu irgendwas?
Ich sehe hier gar keine Bewertungen zu,
man.
Gästebewertung. Schrecklich,
nie wieder. Schrecklich, das Hotel
auf der ganzen Welt.
Die Lage ist mitten im rotlichen
Drogenmilieu. Es gab keine Handtücher,
einen Stuhl bekam ich auf Nachfrage.
Die Zimmertür reichte
nicht bis zum Boden. Man konnte
durch einen großen Spalt in mein Fenster schauen.
Haha.
Geil, das Hotel.
Ich habe so etwas
Chaosiges noch nie erlebt.
Nicht der Fels.
Die Witz spricht nicht den Richtlinien. Okay.
Es war sehr laut.
Die Ausstattung erbärmlich. Es fehlt, es
fehlt die Duschtür.
Das ist fast so gut wie das Hotel in Ulm,
wo ich mal gewesen bin, wo,
ähm, das Klo mitten im Zimmer stand.
Einfach Fliesen auf dem Boden, Klo
mitten im Zimmer.
Der Duschkopf statt eines...
Es fehlten die Duschtür, der Duschkopf
statt eines Fernsehs gab
es nur ein paar lose Kablausern. Das Zimmer
war sehr schmutzig. Es gingen Prostitüde mit ihren
Freien an. Naja gut, das wundert mich
nicht. Das ist mitten im Frankfurter Rotlichtviertel,
ja.
Die ganze Nacht überschrien Leute im Gang.
Das Nebenzimmer war nur durch
provisorische Tür vor meinem Zimmer getrennt.
Und auch zu viel Sehen,
konnte. Boah, nee, Alter.
Außer den Blutflecken
an den Wänden.
Hahaha.
Alter.
Okay, aber das ist aber auch die schlimmste
Ecke in Frankfurt, Mann.
Die Blutflecken an den Wänden.
MonkaS.
Okay.
Okay, ähm, ich zeige euch
nochmal kurz die Copy-Paste, die Copy-Paste
Straßenecke.
Äh,
Frankfurt,
und Chidoba,
Mexican Grill.
Okay. Hier gehe ich öfters
mexikanisch essen.
Das ist so ne, das ist so ne, das ist wie ein Subway.
Nicht, dass man uns da gerade zufällig sieht, ne.
Ähm, oder sieht man, sieht man mich
vielleicht zufällig gerade irgendwie zum, zum
Mexikaner laufen oder so? Nee, nee, nee.
Man sieht niemand.
Niemand, den ich kenne.
Äh, hier gehe ich öfters, ah, das war irgendwann abends oder
morgens, weil hier ist es zu.
Also hier gehe ich ganz gerne, das ist wie
ein Subway, nur für Mexikanisch.
Das Zeug.
Döner, Barber, Kaffee, ja, Copy, genau, das meine ich.
So, und hier vorne ist die Copy-Paste-Straße.
Kann sein, dass ich es euch schon mal gezeigt habe, aber.
Hier ist es auch eklig, wenn du hier langläufst.
Ja, ja, ist auch ein üblicher Verdächtiger.
Aber nicht ganz so schlimm wie an der Niederrachstraße.
So, hier hast du, hier hast du Copy-Paste.
Ja, Stück von der Kaiserstraße hast du hier, Copy-Paste.
Och, nee, man kann nicht.
Och, das ist ja doof.
Wie, kann man nicht hier lang?
Doch, kann man.
Kann man.
Copy-Paste.
Müsst ihr euch das mal angucken.
So, da vorne, das da vorne ist der Hauptbahnhof.
Es ist wirklich immer das gleiche.
Es ist exakt, es ist einfach Copy-Pasted, die Straße.
Man ist super langsam hier beim Durchlaufen gerade.
Ja, ist ja gut, mehr Zickzack, please.
Alles gut, ja, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, jetzt sind wir gleich am, hier vorne ist das übrigens, wo der, what the, what the fuck.
Ah, ich glaube, die konnten nicht weiterfahren, kann das sein.
Weil da die, weil da die Straßenbahn war.
Oh, nein, ey, la.
Hier, hier vorne ist übrigens der Geldautomat.
Wo wir gerade gewesen sind.
So, okay, andere Seite.
Auf der, auf der Seite haben die nix.
Nee.
Okay, also ihr müsst es euch jetzt mal angucken.
Copy, Copy-Paste.
Okay, also.
Es ist immer, es ist immer.
Essen.
Pass auf.
Rieser.
Goldhändler.
Ab und zu noch Hotel.
Und an jeder Einfahrt, okay.
Essen.
Hotel.
Vielleicht, vielleicht Hotel, Hotel, Hotel.
Äh, Goldhändler.
Haarsalon, Goldhändler.
So, nächstes.
Ähm, ja, ähm.
Schuhmacher.
Äh, ja, Kiosk, Dings.
Goldhändler.
Essen, Friseur.
Glaube ich, zumindest.
Nächster.
Essen.
Friseur.
Goldhändler.
Es ist wirklich.
Das ist Copy-Paste.
Die haben das so, als hätten die, als hätten die keinen Bock gehabt und haben das einfach
fünfmal nebeneinander Copy-Pastet.
Es ist immer.
Essen, Hotel, Friseur, Goldhändler.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es hier nicht so weitergeht.
Hier ist es ein bisschen kaputt, ja.
Ah, Mist, jetzt sehen wir es nicht, weil die Straßenbahn im Weg ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Elektronik, Batterien und Spielwaren.
Und Gurken.
Ja.
Ganz klar.
Elektronik, Batterien, Spielwaren und Gurken.
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Kombination.
Kaffee?
Friseur?
Wo ist der Goldhändler?
Gibt es da einen Goldhändler?
Weiß ich nicht.
Sushi-Bar.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Gibt hier kein...
Jetzt sind wir schon am Willy-Brandt-Platz.
Okay, kein Goldhändler mehr.
Kein Goldhändler mehr.
Hier ist übrigens die Ausgabestelle des ersten Euro.
Irgendwo hier.
Das steht ja an irgendeiner Plakette.
Hier wurde der erste Euro ausgegeben.
Nicht an diesem Ding, sondern hier irgendwo.
Irgendwo hier an der Ecke.
Da ist so eine Plakette irgendwie.
Ausgabe der ersten Euro-Münze.
Hier war früher die Europäische Zentralbank.
Das Euro-Zeichen hat sich übrigens gerade despawned, wie ihr seht.
Das ist einfach weg.
Das ist einfach rausgespawned wieder.
Das liegt aber an den Bäumen.
Wobei ich mir nicht mehr sicher bin, ob es immer noch da ist.
Aber ich glaube schon.
Ich sehe das nicht mehr wesentlich.
Hier war früher die Europäische Zentralbank.
Die Europäische Zentralbank ist hier aber nicht mehr.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was hier mittlerweile ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ob da überhaupt was drin ist.
Aber hier ist bis jetzt in der Ecke ganz viele Banken-Zeug.
Hier Commerzbank, Deutsche Bank, DZ Bank.
Alles hier in der Ecke.
Hier war die Europäische Zentralbank.
Jetzt ist die Europäische Zentralbank.
Die hat ein richtig cooles Gebäude.
EZB Frankfurt.
EZB.
Nicht Kaiserstraße.
Ostbahnhof Frankfurt.
Nein.
Ja.
Das hier ist die neue Europäische Zentralbank.
Das sieht ein bisschen schepp aus.
Aber ich finde das mega nice gemacht.
Dieses Gebäude hier.
Also das sieht in echt auch so schepp aus.
Aber es ist nicht schepp.
Also die Kamerabewegung bei Google Maps ist echt Painschamp.
Das ist die neue Europäische Zentralbank.
Das sieht wild aus, ja.
Das ist aber architektonisch, turmäßig, absichtlich so gemacht,
dass es von jeder Seite ein bisschen schepp aussieht.
Ich finde das ist cool.
Das ist echt hin...
Vielleicht sieht man das hier von da aus.
Das ist echt Hingucker, wenn man da vorbeifährt.
Nee, ich war nicht drinnen.
Ja, also das ist echt Hingucker.
Und hier drüben ist übrigens der Fahrradweg,
den ich jetzt schon mal ein paar Mal nach Frankfurt gefahren bin.
Hier, der da.
Äh, nicht wirklich der da, ist egal.
Hier unten Fahrradweg, da.
Mein...
Mein Rad.
Ey, Alter.
Google Street.
Okay, nee, passt.
Nee, passt.
Richtig.
Nicht so ganz.
Ich bin nicht so weit gefahren.
Wo, wo ich wohne?
Tja.
Irgendwo, irgendwo hier, ja.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie wir jetzt da drauf gekommen sind,
aber jetzt haben wir einen kleinen Frankfurt-Rundgang gemacht.
Frankfurt-Goethe-Straße.
Moment.
Goethe-Straße.
Frankfurts.
Gibt's hier nen Dings?
Ah.
Ja.
Frankfurt-Goethe-Straße.
Louis Vuitton-Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Irgendwo hier ist er.
Ich war da noch nie drinne.
Ich kenne ihn auch nur von Haftbefehl.
Und das ist legit die einzigen Zeilen Haftbefehl, die ich kenne.
Also, auswendig.
Hier ist aber schon nicht mehr so schlimm.
Hier ist jetzt schon nicht mehr so wild.
Ja.
Jetzt sind wir wieder am Willy-Brandt-Platz-Klein.
Gut.
Kleiner Frankfurt-Rundgang mit Max zusammen.
Das Hotel war mein Highlight heute.
Pissbock.
Also Leute, ihr wisst schon mal.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Mosel Hotel nicht eure erste Wahl in Frankfurt, wenn ihr in der
Ecke da was sucht.
Zumindest laut Bewertungen.
So.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Wir hören uns, Leute.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
C U.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020